la séance est
ouverte l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au
Gouvernement la première question va
être posée par madame Béatrice Descamp
pour le groupe Liot
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé 4 millions c'est le nombre de
Français atteints de diabète selon le
rapport charge et produit ils seront
500000 de plus à la fin de ce quinquen
les chiffres sont alarmants et en cette
Journée Mondiale du Diabète je souhaite
porter la voix de ces patients qui sont
de réels acteurs de leur maladie vous le
savez monsieur le ministre les Français
atteints de diabète doivent s'astreindre
dès leur diagnostic à modifieré leurs
habitudes de vie et une large proportion
d'entre eux doivent surveiller eux-mêmes
leur taux de glycémie selon les
recommandations de la Haute Autorité de
santé daté de 2011 un patient diabétique
est tenu de se piquer une dizaine de
fois par jour pour surveiller sa
glycémie or monsieur le ministre cette
recommandation qui doit guider les
professionnels de santé dans la prise en
charge des patients est obsolète et à 10
ans de retard depuis une dizaine
d'années les traitements la gestion de
la maladie et notamment les méthodes de
surveillance glycémique ont
considérablement évolué monsieur le
ministre l'innovation en santé
prolifique c'est particulièrement le cas
pour le diabète et nous nous en
réjouissons mais sans traduction dans
nos politiques de santé cette innovation
ne trouvera pas sa place auprès des
patients il est temps de faire en sorte
que les recommandations de prise en
charge évoluent pour refléter les
nouvelles options diagnostiques et
thérapeutiques mais aussi l'implication
de l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé autour du médecin généraliste dans
la g quotidienne des patients ma
question est simple quand la hasas dont
je salue par ailleurs le travail
mettra-t-elle à jour ces recommandations
au profit de la prise en charge des
différents
diabètes merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau ministre de
la santé et de la
prévention madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée je ne pratique pas la réponse
aux questions au gouvernement depuis
longtemps mais je sais qu'il est d'usage
de remercier quel que soit l'intérêt
qu'on porte à la question la personne
qui vous la pose mais là je voudrais
vous remercier très sincèrement très
sincèrement de poser et de mettre en
lumière ce sujet majeur en cette Journée
Mondiale du Diabète journée mondiale
depuis
1991 vous l'avez dit 4 millions de nos
concitoyens sont touché par le diabète
et on a tendance à banaliser ce que ça
signifie vous l'avez très bien dit le
diabète c'est vivre tous les jours avec
la pathologie devoir adapter son
traitement dev vooir se suivre et donc
il est très important aujourd'hui de
saluer et de penser aux patients c'est
d'autant plus important que la crise du
covid nous a montré à quel point le
diabète est une pathologie qui a des
conséquences systémiques et dans la
surmortalité liée au covid on a retrouvé
beaucoup de patients diabétiques je
voudrais souligner que beaucoup des de
progrès ont été effectués notamment je
crois que les démarches de prévention la
lutte contre la
sédentarité notamment l'activité
physique sont des axes forts contre le
diabète il a nous avons aussi progressé
en matière de télésurveillance à
domicile c'est un point très important
pour la qualité de vie du patient mais
je crois que et vous le dites très bien
nous avons nous devons être à la hauteur
et aller à la vitesse des innovations
thérapeutiques les les patients sont
prêts à être des acteurs de leur propre
santé les patients diabétiques ce sont
sans doute les mieux armés pour le faire
nous allons les accompagner encore plus
notamment dans les dispositifs de
télésurveillance et dans le financement
de nouveaux traitements et par ailleurs
je vous confirme que la hasas j'aichangé
avec son président il y a quelques jours
produira dans les tous prochains mois
c'est à son programme de travail du
prochain semestre les recommandations
pour le diabète de type 2 pour adapter
celle qui avait été faite il y a 10 ans
merci madame la députée merci beaucoup
monsieur le
ministre la prochaine question va être
posée par Madame Pascale Bor pour le
rassemblement
national madame la Présidente chers
collègues madame la Première ministre la
montée des actes antisémites des
agressions contre nos compatriotes Juifs
les PO grames auxquels nous avons
assisté en Israël avec les attaques
terroristes du Hamas nous rappelle que
l'ignominie des hommes et les idéologies
de haine sont prêtes à surg dès que nous
baissons la garde dès que la défense du
bien plie devant la faiblesse dès que le
souci de l'avenir cède à l'
l'imprévision en faisant le choix
inconsidéré de faire rentrer en France
sans discernement ni contrôle des
millions d'immigrés la classe politique
a aussi fait entrer et même organiser
l'entrée dans notre pays de gens
prosélites porteur d'une idéologie
sanguinaire
l'islamisme sois bien clair je ne
confonds pas les musulmans qui
pratiquent leur religion de manière
paisible et fraternelle avec les
islamistes de la même manière je ne
confonds pas les Palestiniens avec le
Hamas qui s'en sert comme bouclier
humain face au fléau de l'antisémitisme
le pays a a opposé par une manifestation
unitaire et particulièrement digne dont
chacun doit se féliciter la
démonstration de sa réprobation absolue
face à ce qui touche à l'essentiel
toute division devient un acte de
complicité
objective pour autant parce que nous le
devons à l'histoire parce que nous le
devons aux victimes de cette barbarie
mais aussi pour l'avenir parce que nous
le devons à nos enfants les
protestations aussi éploré que forte
soit-elle ne suffisent pas elles ne
feront reculer aucun fanatique aucun
prêcheur de haine aucun idiot utile de
l'islamisme pourtant force de constater
au des dernières déclarations de membres
du gouvernement ou de la majorité que
vous n'osez même pas désigner
l'idéologie qui soutend la haine
antisémitisme et qui parfois arme la
main des tueurs on ne combat pas on ne
combat pas une menace quand on est
incapable de la nom madame la Première
ministre qu'alz-vous faire pour
combattre
l'islam la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
Verand ministre en charge du renouveau
démocratique et porte-parole du
gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la présidente madame la députée Pascale
borde Koulibali Mohamed Mera et de
nombreux autres djihadistes ont commis
des attentats antisémistes sur notre sol
au nom de l'idéologie islamiste et cela
personne ne le niit le gouvernement
lutte avec acharnement
contre
monsieur Habib s'il vous
plaît monsieur
Habib encore une fois je vous rappelle à
l'ordre le gouvernement lutte avec
détermination évidemment contre le
fanatisme monsieur Habib monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement lutte avec
détermination contre le radicalisme
islamiste qui tue contre le radicalisme
islamiste qui commet des actes
antisémites le gouvernement madame la
députée vous avez commencé par poser une
question sur l'antisémitisme et vous la
termininez par la lutte contre
l'islamisme en réalité le
[Musique]
gouvernement le gouvernement lutte avec
détermination contre toutes les formes
d'antisémitisme lutte avec détermination
contre toutes les idéologies mortifères
qui visent à diviser les Français les
uns contre les autres toutes les
idéologies d'où qu'elles viennent qui
mettre en insécurité nos concitoyens
juifs il y en a hélas madame la députée
en dehors du cadre de islam et nous ne
négligeons pas et ce que les Français
ont été nombreux à dire à Paris à
Grenoble à Toulouse et dans beaucoup de
villes de France dimanche c'est que
l'antisémitisme les antisémitismes il y
en a pas un bon et un mauvais madame la
députée toutes ces formes
d'antisémitisme qui gangrenent notre
société non'ont pas notre place n'ont
pas leur place en France et croyez en
notre détermination pour lutter contre
je vous remercie monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
ministre la parole s'il vous plaît un
peu de silence la parole est à
monsieurésid président maard pour le
groupe
Renaissance merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre dimanche
dernier ce sont plus de 180000 personnes
qui ont défilé dans les rues de 70
villes partout en France qui ont marché
pour la République contre
l'antisémitisme avec le président du
Sénat je veux saluer votre appel madame
la
Présidente
ces marches ont été pour reprendre les
mots du président de la République dans
sa lettre au français un motif
d'espérance ce soulèvement de la nation
et celui de tout un peuple face à la
haine antisémite car l'antisémitisme ce
n'est pas pas chre horrible que l'on
égraine 1518 actes rien qu'en un mois ce
sont des Françaises et des Français
comme vous comme moi comme vous comme
vous qui vivent dans la terreur du fait
de la leur confession c'est Max 20 ans
qui en rentrant l'université à NZ cassé
parce qu'il est juif c'est Alain qui
porte une quiipa et sur qui l'on crache
le genou à terre c'est Samuel qui depuis
30 ans n'est plus allé dans son
université médecine après avoir reçu des
insultes et des coups ou Sarah dont le
fils de 8 ans a remis des couche la nuit
par peur d'aller à l'école je tiens
aujourd'hui à remercier nos policiers
nos militaires qui chaque jour
s'assurent de leur
sécurité mais aucun citoyen français ne
devrait avoir à vivre cela car la haine
des Juifs c'est le signe du délitement
de de notre République tout comme les
faunées de l'antisémitisme que sont
l'antisionisme et le négationisme
défendu sur certains de ces bancs madame
la Première ministre comment mettre un
terme à cette dangereuse recrudescence
de l'antisémitisme dans notre pays je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le président Sylvain Maillard
depuis le 7 octobre et l'attaque
terroriste du Hamas contre
Israël nous assistons à une augmentation
sans précédent des actes antisémites
dans notre pays en un mois ce sont plus
de 1500 actes qui ont été constatés
c'est plus que sur une année une année
entière les Français de confessions
juives vivent dans l'angoisse c'est
grave c'est inadmissible dans la
République où personne ne doit être
inquiété en raison de ses
croyances monsieur le Président Maillard
face à ces actes il y a d'abord notre
action résolue nous avons passé des
consignes de vigilance extrême au préfet
nos forces de l'ordre les militaires de
l'opération sentinelle sont mobilisés
pour assurer la sécurité des lieux
sensibles en particulier les les lieux
de culte ou les écoles nous avons
également demandé la du grande fermeté
au parquet des enquêtes sont lancées des
condamnations sont prononcées jusqu'à 18
mois dans certains cas mais monsieur le
Président Maillard vous avez raison de
le dire face à
l'antisémitisme une réaction unanime et
sans ambigué est
indispensable lutter contre
l'antisémitisme c'est l'affaire de tous
s'en prendre à une personne parce
qu'elle est juive c'est s'en prendre à
la République notre devoir
contes les
Haes monsieur le Président Maillard
dimanche à l'initiative de la
présidente BR PIV pardon que je tiens à
saluer et à celle du président du Sénat
Gérard larch la France a été au
rendez-vous pour dire non à
l'antisémitisme et pour défendre avec
force les valeurs de la
[Applaudissements]
République C pouvoir faire oublier d'où
ils viennent je ne reviendrai pas non
plus sur l'attitude de ceux qui refusent
de marcher contre l'antisémitisme et ont
tenté de salir cette marche à coup de
mensonge
indigne je n'ai pas besoin d'en dire
plus car les Français leur ont répondu
ils ont répondu en marchant très
nombreux contre toutes les haines ils
ont répondu dans l'unité au-delà des
opinions et des croyances ils ont
répondu avec dignité clarté et dans le
rassemblement ensemble nous l'avons
affirmé nous combattrons l'antisémitisme
jusqu'au bout la haine n'a pas sa place
dans la République je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
ministre la parole est à Monsieur thiba
Bazin pour le Coupet
républicain
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre le logement est en
crise et vos décisions y ont contribué
après avoir en 2018 quasi supprimé la
paiaccession et divisé par 2 la qutité
finançable du prêt àau zéro pour 94 %
des communes votre bilan est
catastrophique alors qu'en 2011 près de
351000 PTZ étaient accordés ce nombre a
chuté à 63000 en 2022 votre gouvernement
a annoncé vouloir élargir le PTZ nous
l'espérions mais quand on regarde dans
le détail ce que vous prévoyez cela
ressemble à une super cherie vous clamez
que vos mesures permettront à 6 millions
de foyers supplémentaire d'accéder à ce
dispositif mais dans les faits la
Fédération bancaire française estime
qu'au maximum 15000 nouveaux ménages
bénéficieront de l'augmentation des
plafonds de ressources on est loin des 6
millions et le PTZ ne pourra financer
que 20 % de l'achat pour ces nouveaux
ménages éligibles contre 40 % auparavant
plus inquiétant encore vous voulez
exclure du PTZ l'achat d'une maison
neuve ce qui revient de facto exclure
plus d'un tiers des anciens
bénéficiaires du PTZ au final on risque
d'avoir encore moins d'accédents vous
affirmez avec fierté ajouter 209
communes au dispositif mais la réalité
c'est qu'avec ces modifications 93 % des
communes verront leurs habitants privés
de toute aide pour la construction de
leur résidence principale les fractures
territoriales vont encore s'aggraver
madame la Première ministre
qu allez-vous enfin rétablir une
politique de véritable soutien à
l'acession à la propriété sur l'ensemble
du territoire quand allez-vous enfin
répondre à l'aspiration des Français qui
deent devenir propriétaire de leur
maison je vous
remercie la parole est à monsieur
Clément B ministre en charge des
transports madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les
députésieur le député
Bazin je vous prie de silence s'il vous
plaît un peu de silence le gouvernement
choisit sa représentation allez-y
monsieur le ministre vous prie de bien
vouloir je vois que ça suscite un peu
d'émotion je prie de bien vouloir
excuser l'absence de Patrice vergrit
ministre du Logement qui est en cours de
réunion européenne en ce moment même il
ne pouvait pas être présent cet
après-midi vous avez raison nous sommes
face à une nous sommes face à une grave
crise du logement qui ne concerne pas
que notre pays et sur laquelle le
gouvernement est mobilisé avec avec de
multiples réponses je veux répondre à
certains des points que vous avez
soulevés d'abord sur les causes de cette
crise il faut être précis elle est
d'abord liée à la multiplication par tro
des taux d'intérêt qui impactent
effectivement et massivement le pouvoir
d'achat immobilier des Français elle est
aussi liée à un certain nombre de
contraintes d'offre la hausse des coûts
de construction le prix du foncier qui
est plus élevé et des contraintes de
procédurees des contraintes
administratives y compris locales qui se
conjuguent et se cumulent et ne
permettent pas de réduire aujourd'hui
les prix pour les adapter à cette crise
des taux nous avons multiplié les
réponses pour que nous nous soyons
capablebles de répondre aux différents
facteurs de cette crise l'objectif est
très clair il est de proposer des
logements de qualité abordables à
proximité des lieux d'emploi cela
suppose aussi et le ministre verg du
travail une implication des
collectivités local auquel le
gouvernement nous l'avons dit enant
confier de nouveaux moyens et de
nouvelles responsabilités dans le cadre
d'une loi de décentralisation qui sera
débatue ici même en 2024 à court terme
le gouvernement agit vous avez rappelé
quelques outils pour développer
notamment le logement locatif
intermédiaire pour élargir en effet le
préateau zéro et le ministre vergrd
continue à travailler sur ce dispositif
vous avez cité un certain nombre de
sujets à continuer à explorer à
améliorer et nous facilitons aussi
l'accès au crédit en développant
l'accession sociale nous augmentons par
ailleurs la capacité d'investissement
des bailleurs sociaux c'est le sens du
document qui a été signé avec le
mouvement Hlm permettant des engagements
de plus d'un milliard d'euros face à la
multiplicité des causes de la crise nous
devons avoir des réponses multiples et
notamment travailler sur la question on
des compétences avec les collectivités
locales c'est le sens de l'AC de
décentralisation que nous avons annoncé
le ministre vergrit aura l'occasion
aussi de répondre àre proposition de loi
monsieur député ministre merci Monsieur
Bazin monsieur le ministre votre réponse
n'est pas à la hauteur de la crise du
logement que connaît notre pays alors
que les taux d'intérêt augmentent il
faut vraiment renforcer le préatau zéro
sur l'ensemble du territoire et pas
seulement sur certains territoires
privilégiés alors que les taux d'intérêt
augmenté que la construction en panne il
y a urgence à prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour pour soutenir non
seulement l'accession à la propriété
mais aussi la rénovation sur l'ensemble
du territoire mon député je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Charles arsonur pour le groupe
horizon merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre près de 15
jours après le passage des tempêtes
Karan Domingos nous sommes toujours dans
une situation d'urgence en Bretagne à
l'heure où nous parlons 5000 foyers sont
encore privé d'électricité dans le
Finistère j'adresse tout mon soutien aux
personnes plongées dans le noir le Frid
et l'isolement j'exprime également ma
pleine solidarité avec les habitants du
Nord et du pas decalais confrontés à des
cru dévastatrices un grand merci à la
préfecture du finisterère pour ses
points quotidiens avec les élus à nos
maires et à leurs équipes placés en
première ligne à tous les personnels
mobilisés y compris ce venu en soutien
d'autres régions nous commençons à peine
à chiffrer l'ampleur des dégâts tous les
réseaux sont tombé électricité
télécommunication fixes et mobiles et
même le potable en particulier dans nos
campagnes les dégâts sont considérables
sur les bâtiments publics comme les
écoles et dans l'agriculture je pense à
nos éleveurs et à nos séristes durement
touchés le retour à la normale prendra
du temps néanmoins nos concitoyens sont
ont un besoin de visibilité sur le
rétablissement de l'électricité deux
questions madame la Première ministre en
premier lieu l'état de catastrophe
naturelle et le régime des calamités
agricoles ne sont pas aisés à activer
dans de tes circonstances où en
sommes-nous l'outil d'un fond d'urgence
est-il à privilégié pouvons-nous
envisager un complément de Dr pour les
collectivités les plus touchées en 2024
et en 2ème lieu quel dispositif
entendez-vous mettre en place en terme
de retour d'expérience sur la résilience
de nos réseaux il a été difficile en
effet voir impossible de joindre les
mares et de s'adresser la population
pendant plusieurs jours faut-il
envisager de doter les mairies de radio
de radio satellite de groupes
électrogènes de multiplier les exercices
de gestion de crise à long terme
envisageons-nous de débloquer des moyens
afin d'enterrer les lignes électriques
pour sécuriser les réseaux dans les
régions les plus exposées je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame
Dominique fort ministre en charge des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député Jean-Charles
Larsonneur d'abord vous dire tout le
soutien du gouvernement à la violence de
cette tempête en Bretagne mais vous
l'avez dit aussi vous AZ on est tous
solidairirees des cru dans le Nord et
dans le pas decalé les dommages causés
par les vents violents sont tout d'abord
couverts et ça vous le savez par la
garantie tempête qui est prévu dans le
code des assurances cette garantie
permet une indemnisation directe par les
assureurs des biens sinistrés des
collectivités territoriales sans qu'une
déclaration préalable de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle par les pouvoirs
publics soit nécessaire de plus le
président de la République en
déplacement dans le Finistère le 3
novembre s'est engagé au déclenchement
rapide de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle et de celui de calamité
agricole partout où on pourra le faire
la réunion du comité catastrophe
naturelle s tenu ce jour Monsieur le
Député en tout début d'après-midi les
arrêtés seront pris demain cela concerne
tant les particuliers que les
collectivités territoriales par ailleurs
au-delà du cadre assuranciel des
mécanismes de soutien spécifiques et
vous les appelez de vos vœux sont
mobilisables par les collectivités pour
les dommages aux équipements publics non
assurables celles-ci peuvent se
prévaloir du régime de la dotation de
solidarité et ainsi bénéficier de crédit
pour leurs ouvrages d'art leurs
infrastructures leurs parc leurs jardin
leurs digu ou leurs station
d'épuration le gouvernement sera
également présent au côté des
agriculteurs via la mobilisation des
dispositifs de droit commun le
dégrèvement de taxes sur le foncier non
bâti et le report de cotisation sociale
et puis l'indemnité de solidarité
nationale en cas de perte catastrophique
de récolte par ailleurs via le fond
d'aide au relogement d'urgence le Faru
les collectivités prenant en charge le
relogement d'urgence peuvent bénéficier
de subvention à hauteur de so 75 % à
100% des dépenses monsieur le député
vous nous interrogez enfin sur la chaîne
de communication des acteurs publics en
cas de crise et vous avez raison je veux
simplement saluer une fois de plus ici
la mobilisation exceptionnelle conjointe
du binô préfet et maire au service de
nos concitoyens je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député merci Madame la
Ministre les finistérien compte sur vous
c'est important pour les agriculteurs
c'est important pour les collectivités
c'est important pour les habitants je
vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Nathalie ool pour le groupe la France
insoumise madame la Première ministre il
y a 5 jours alors qu'on ComptAÉ plus de
10000 morts à Gaza Emmanuel Macron a
appelé pour la première fois à in cesser
le feu il a plus tard ajouté qu'il n'y a
aucune raison et aucune légitimité à
bombarder et tuer des bébés des femmes
des personnes âgées cet appel bien que
tardif était salutaire mais il lui a
valu d'être aussitôt accusé de planter
un couteau dans le dos de la communauté
juive et de frôer l'antisémitisme sur la
chaîne i24 news le président de la
République et la diplomatie française
ont aussi été prises à parti par le CRIF
qui niant la responsabilité de l'État
d'Israël dans les massacres des civils
palestiniens s'est permis de demander
une clarification de la position de la
France dimanche ce qui devait être une
marche contre l'antisémitisme a été le
lieu d'appel au meurtrre contre la
France insoumise contre Jean Mélenchon
et contre le président de la République
des journalistes ont été agressés des
militants pour la paix en Palestine ont
été frappés les musulmans ont été la
cible de propos racistes insupportabl et
pendant que le petit monde politico
médiatique français se gargarise de
cette journée désastreuse la presse
étrangère est sidérée par le blanchiment
de l'extrême droite qui a lieu en France
sur le dos de la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme à la France insoumise
nous refusons que soit rétrécie la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme contre le racisme
et contre l'extrême droite qui en est le
premier vecteur nous refusons que soit
encouragé l'affrontement des Françaises
et des Français de confessions juives et
ceux de confessions musulmanes chaque
samedi les marches pour le cesser le feu
et pour la paix sont une formidable
démonstration d'unité du peuple madame
la Première ministre condamnez-vous les
propos racistes contre nos compatriotes
musulmans le ministère de l'Intérieur
va-t-il interdire la Ligue de Défense
Juive condamnez-vous le communiqué du
CRIF et les propos tenus contre le
président de la République je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colona ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires
[Applaudissements]
étrangères merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée osiol je vrais vous rappeler
que depuis le 7 octobre la positionition
de la France est constante et basée sur
nos principes Israël victime d'attaque
terroristes abominaable j'espère que
vous le reconnaissez a le droit de se
défendre et de protéger sa population
contre le Hamas et le devoir nous le
disons de se défendre dans le cadre du
respect du droit international et en
particulier Israël doit faire tout son
possible pour protéger les populations
civiles c'est une obligation légale et
une obligation morale nous l'avons dit
souvent et je le redis volontiers ici
mais il faut rappeler madame la députée
que de la même façon ce que fait le
Hamas en utilisant des hôpitaux des
écoles en rampe de lancement de
roquettes ou en installation militaire
viole le droit international et doit
être pareillement condamné en agissant
ainsi le Hamas met siamment la
population palestinienne en péril face à
l'urgence humanitaire qui est réelle la
France a organisé le 9 novembre une
conférence humanitaire internationale
pour la population civile de Gaza outre
le milliard d'euros annoncé grâce à
cette conférence celle-ci a permis
d'acter un consensus international en
faveur d'une trêve immédiate qui puisse
garantir que l'aide parvienne aux
populations et répondre aux besoins de
celle-ci c'est un pas important c'est un
pas concret puis il faudra uvrer un
cesser le feu le président de la
République l'a dit et enfin il faudra
restaurer un horizon politique c'est
d'ailleurs une position constante de la
France que de le rappeler la France ne
l'a jamais oublié la seule solution
viable c'est celle de deux états vivant
en paix côte à côte nous y travaillons
avec nos partenaires et il est plus que
temps d'avancer je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame
Jacqueline Maquet pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre chargé des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité je m'adresse à vous au nom de
Philippe
dont les circonscriptions ont été
amplement touché par des inondations ils
sont retenus par la visite du président
de la
République en quelques minutes il y
avait 1 M50 d'eau chez moi c'est
vraiment une catastrophe j'ai pris une
échelle pour monter sur mon toit car
l'eau montait vite très vite mes animaux
vont mourir j'ai peur de mourir ce sont
les mots d'habitants du montrelois du
Boulonnais du calis et de l'odomarois
qui ont ont vu leur maison être pris par
les EAU des centaines de familles
sinistrées des milliers de personnes
déplacées des centaines de logements
inondés des entreprises à l'arrêt des
voiries emportées des bâtiments publics
fragilisés des exploitations agricool
décimé et avec cela le fruit de toute
une vie de labeur ces ces inondations se
révèlent bien plus graves de jour en
jour au-delà de toutes ces images il y a
cet élan de solidarité une entraide
nature
envers les plus faibles de nombreux
habitants se me en sauteur au côté des
centaines de policiers gendarmes sapeurs
pompiers agents de sécurité civile
association et organismes de secours
leur engagement est exceptionnel 2300
interventions 1400 personnes évacuées
des centaines de communes sécurisées
tout simplement merci à eux dès les
premières heures les maires les élus du
territoire et leurs équipes ont répondu
présent chaque jour chaque nuit il se
démène et porte haut les valeurs de
notre nation le gouvernement est au
travail l'état de catastrophe naturelle
est déjà reconnu pour 214 communes à
court TER court terme crit de la
reconstruction et du relogement des
sinistré à long terme nous devons nous
engager sur la prévention de la montée
des EAU la limitation des phénomènes de
ruissellement merci beaucoup les
habitants nous le demandent mais nous le
réclam également madame la ministre le
pcal a besoin de pouvez-vous nous
redonner de l'ES merci
beaucoup madame Dominique fort ministre
en charge des collectivités
territoriales et de la ruralité vous
avez la parole merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la député Jacqueline
Maquet nous nous associons à vos
remerciements pour la mobilisation des
policiers des gendarmes des agents de la
sécurité civil des associations
organismes de secours qui ont fait un
travail extraordinaire en cette période
de crise n nous associons et nous sommes
tous solidaires des milliers de
personnes sinistrées le pas decaléis a
effectivement connu un événement
plusuvieux intense ces derniers jours
qui faisaient suite à des cumuls déjà
exceptionnels intervenant dans un
contexte hydrologique extrêmement
préoccupant sur les 247 communes qui ont
été touchées la priorité est à la
réponse d'urgence et au retour à la
normale 550 foyers restent privés
d'électricité celle-ci ne pourra être
rétablie par les services enedis que
lorsque le niveau de l'eau permettra de
mettre hors d'eau les postes électriques
92 axes routiers soit 150 km de route
restent encore coupés les établissements
scolaires demeurent fermé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui vous évoquez la question du
relogement des sinistrés la prise en
charge s'est concentrée sur les
personnes vulnérables depuis le 6
novembre 54 d'entre elles ont été prises
en charge par l'ARS dans un hébergement
dédié en ce qui concerne la
reconstruction suite aux dégâts causés
par les inondations les personnes
physiques résidants dans l'une des 244
communes ayant fait l'objet d'une
reconnaissance par l'État de
catastrophes naturelles pourront faire
l'objet d'une indamnisation des dommages
causés au bien assurés ce qui devrait
permettre une et favoriser la
reconstruction une cellule dédiée aux
entreprises et aux exploitants agricoles
a également été mise en place par la
préfecture la fréquence et l'intensité
de ces phénomènes climatiques ayant
vocation à s'accélérer dans le cadre du
réchauffement climatique nous devons
adapter nos territoires pour y faire
face et c'est le sens du nouveau plan
national d'adaptation de la France au
changement climatique qui est porté par
Christophe Béchu et qui sera lancé en
début d'année 2024 je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la ministre la
parole est à Madame Francesca paschini
pour le groupe écologiste merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères madame la ministre je je
pense que nous sommes d'accord un enfant
où qu'il se trouve dans le monde mérite
notre protection la France s'est engagée
à le faire il y a plus de 30 ans en
ratifiant la Convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant qui a une valeur
juridique contraignante obligatoire et
non négociable que l'enfant en danger se
trouve à quelques mètres de nous ou à
Gaza nous nous devons d'agir trop peu de
voix s'élèv pour décrire la la tragédie
des enfants de Gaza la moitié des
Gazaoui sont des enfants depuis le 8
octobre 4500 enfants sont morts en
moyenne 120 par jour et 8600 sont
blessés et 1500 sont portés disparus
parmi les blessés certains ont été
amputés sans anesthésie générale faute
de médicaments l'UNICEF est clair Gaza
et devenu je cite un cimetière pour
enfants la vie d'un million d'entre eux
ne tient plus qu'à un fil il payent un
lourd tribut et le temps presse pour
leur venir en aide pour ceux qui sonent
encore en vie la peur la faim et la soif
les tenailles l'eau l'électricité et le
traitement des EAU usées sont coupées
avec les conséquences sanitaires que
vous imaginez cela vient s'ajouter au
traumatisme qui les accompagneront toute
leur vie les actes du gouvernement
israélien sont en totale contradiction
avec la Convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant que l'État d'Israël a
pourtant ratifié la France ne doit pas
rester passif face à ces crimes de
guerre dont des milliers d'enfants sont
victimes avec l'appui de plusieurs
collègues députés nous avons demandé à
la délégation au droits des enfants de
lancer une mission sur le sort des
enfants Gazaoui pouvez-vous nous
indiquer madame la ministre quelles sont
les mesures concrètes prises par le
gouvernement pour porter secours et
assistance à ses enfants merci je vais
remercie ma cher collègue la parole est
à Madame Catherine Colona ministre des
Affaires étrangères et des affaires
européennes merci madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée Pasquini vous avez raison oui
de soulever l'urgence humanitaire car
les besoins sont criants à Gaza l'aide
doit pouvoir passer doit pouvoir passer
en en plus grand nombre au point de
passage de de Rafa et être distribué
ensuite aux populations civil pour
répondre à leurs besoins nous ajoutons
toujours répondre à leurs besoins de
façon durable alors la communauté
internationale s'est mobilisée la France
y a pris sa part avec déjà 88 tonnes de
fretes qui ont été livré sur place et
maintenant cette aide doit passer il est
clair qu'il faut faire davantage c'est
pour cette raison que la France a
organisé jeudi dernier la conférence que
j'ai évoqué avec ces principaux
partenaires internationaux régionaux
Nations Unies organisation spécialisées
et outre les contributions rassemblées
dont celle de la France qui a été portée
à 100 millions d'euros cette conférence
a permis d'acter un consensus en faveur
d'une trêve immédiate durable soutenue
qui puisse garantir que l'aide parvienne
au population c'est un pas important
c'est un pas concret puisque vous
appelez à des gestes concrets nous
poursuivrons nos efforts pour
matérialiser cela sur le terrain au plus
vite parce que bien sûr madame la
députée chaque jour compte chaque vie
compte qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs de la
vie d'un enfant ou de la vie d'un adulte
je souhaite aussi répéter que la lutte
contre le terrorisme doit se faire
conformément au droit international
c'est un impératif légal un impératif
moral et c'est la force des démocraties
que de mener la lutte contre les
terrorises
dans le respect du droit international
nous ne cesserons de le rappeler je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Elsa
fossillon pour le groupe
GDR merci madame la présidente mesdames
et messieurs les ministres à Gaza ceux
qui survivent aux bombes risquent de
mourir de faim de soif ou faute de soins
11240 Palestiniens ont été tués par les
bombardements israéliens depuis les
attaques terroristes du Hamas Gaza est
devenu un cimetière pour enfants 4630
sont déjà morts et alors que des les
hôpitaux bénéficient d'une protection
particulière en vertu du droit
international humanitaire des
témoignages et des images d'horreur nous
proviennent de l'hôpital alchifa à Gaza
aujourd'hui plus de 22 des 35 hôpitaux
sont en arrêt total ou partiel avec la
pénurie de carburant sans électricité
eau ou nourriture c'est le chaos qui
règne selon l'OCHA agence onusienne le
nombre de déplacés s'élève maintenant à
1,6 million de personnes sur les 2,4
millions de Gazaoui et en même temps en
6jordanie nous assistons à des centaines
d'attaques par des colons et des
expulsions de communauté bédouin
194 Palestiniens ont été tués par
l'armée et par des milices de Colon des
ministres israéliens ont été jusqu'à se
mettre en scène en train de distribuer
des armes à des colons cela c'est la
traduction du projet de Benyamin
netanahou le même qu'avant les attaques
du Hamas c'est l'occupation c'est la
volonté d'une occupation complète de la
Palestine et à Gaza l'escalade
vengeresse se transforme en nettoyage
ethnique pourtant depuis
1948 ce sont 104 résolutions de l'ONU
sur la situation en Palestine 104 qui
sont restés lêrre mortes pendant cette
période la communauté internationale est
restée inerte silencieuse et donc
impuissante il y a quelques jours
Emmanuel Macron a fmement dit la
nécessité d'aller vers un cesser le feu
enfin mais ça semble en permanence redit
par d'autres phrases par exemple lors de
son contact avec le président israélien
la paix vous paraît peut-être impensable
nous croyons qu'elle est possible elle
nécessite des actes forts tout doit
mettre être mis en re pour le cesser le
feu merci la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colona ministre des Affaires
étrangères et de
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
fossillon à Gaza quelle est l'urgence
oui bien sûr l'urgence la première
urgence est humanitaire elle est que
l'aide qui est stockée du côté égyptien
puisse passer à la population civile de
Gaza pour répondre aux besoins criants
des populations et donc l'urgence oui
c'est cela ne pas laisser ne pas laisser
une catastrophe humanitaire s'aggraver
apporter de l'aide de façon urgente et
durable alors bien sûr cela impose une
pause dans les opérations militaires
pour que les soignants puissent entrer
pour que l'aide puisse être distribuer
pour que les blessés les plus graves
puissent être évacués à partir de là il
faut être pragmatique que peut-on
aujourd'hui obtenir je dis bien
aujourd'hui une trêve humanitaire
immédiate qui ensuite pourra mener à un
cesser le feu et c'est ce consensus
international que la France a contribué
à forger lors de la conférence
humanitaire jeudi dernier donc il faut
une pause le plus rapidement possible et
sans attendre il faut aussi uvrer un
cesser le feu et à la restauration d'une
perspective politique mais mais sans
permettre au Hamas de reconstituer ses
capacités et de mener ces actions
terroristes car nul ne doit oublier quel
est l'objectif de cette organisation
terroriste et surtout ne pas l'oublier
après ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre ne
l'oublions pas rien ne justifie jamais
le terrorisme
merci merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Mathieu Marchot pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion monsieur le ministre
328000 c'est le nombre de chômeurs en
France au 3è trimestre de cette année
plus de 3 millions de Français sans
emploi monsieur le ministre un chiffre
en augmentation de 0,6 % au dernier
trimestre alors que tant de nos
compatriotes sont au chômage partout en
France dans les outr-mers comme dans le
Nord votre seule réponse est de
régulariser des clandestins une
régularisation qui va créer un nouvel
appel d'air à toujours plus
d'immigration pour tous les Français
vivant dans la précarité et au chômage
vous êtes décidément hors sol déconnecté
de la réalité de ceux qui souffrent
votre projet est un nonsens économique
car en faisant appel à plus
d'immigration vous tirez à la baisse les
salaires de l'ensemble des travailleurs
créant ainsi une situation de
concurrence
déloyale notamment dans les emplois
difficiles et souvent mal payés c'est
bien sur ce sujet que vous devriez vous
concentrer en priorité en tant que
ministre du Travail aujourd'hui le
travail coûte plus qu'il ne rapporte
pour bon nombre de nos concitoyens il
faut que le travail paye en augmentant
de 10 % les bas salaires comme le
propose Marine Le Pen en revalorisant le
travail manuel qui ne saurait être
exercé que par des clandestins exploités
honteusement en améliorant les
conditions de travail dans le secteur de
la logistique par exemple en réduisant
le coût du carburant monsieur le
ministre vous qui avez été socialiste
puis macroniste vous êtes associé à une
politique économique et pro immigration
qui a fait tant de mal aux Français
votre projet incarne le pire entre
l'ouverture de la gauche à l'immigration
et l'ouverture à l'ultralibéralisme de
la droite cette alliance néfaste qui a
mis le bassin minier du Nord dont je
suis élu à terre alors Monsieur le
Ministre quel est l'intérêt de vous de
vouloir régulariser des clandestins dans
un pays qui compte plus de 3 millions
beaucoup de
chur la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
duopt ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs mon députés monsieur le député
Marquot vous prenez prétexte d'une des
dispositions de la loi en cours d'examen
sur l'immigration et l'intégration pour
aborder la question du chômage d'abord
permettez-moi de rappeler que la
disposition que nous avions envisagé
avec Gérald haranin et la disposition
qui a été votée par le Sénat avec des
critères durcis et en renvoyant un
pouvoir discrétionnaire du préfet n'a
qu'un objectif un seul qui est permettre
effectivement de régulariser non pas de
nouveaux immigrés non pas des personnes
qui travaillent de manière illégale mais
d'apporter une possibilité de
régularisation à des hommes et des
femmes qui sont présents sur notre
territoire qui travaillent depuis
longtemps et qui travaillent légalement
parce que ne vous en déplais dans notre
pays on peut avoir un contrat de travail
sans avoir titre de séjour bien souvent
ce sont des personnes qui ont signé un
contrat de travail quand ils avaient un
titre de séjour et qui n'a pas été
renouvelé monsieur le député vous dites
à travers cette question et je ne
préjuge pas du débat qui s'interviendra
dans les prochains jours vous dites la
priorité c'est faire baisser le chômage
en France nous la partageons nous la
partageons tellement que depuis 6 ans
l'économie française grâce à la
politique que nous menons a créé 2
millions d'emplois nous la partageons
parce qu'au cours de la dernière année
l'économie française a créé 140000
emploi net nous la partageons mais vous
ne la partagez pas monsieur le député
vous ne la partagez pas parce que quand
on vote une réforme de l'assurance
chômage pour que les règles soi plus
incitatives vous n'êtes pas là et vous
votez contre quand on débat pour faire
en sorte que les allocateurs du RSA
puisse participer à 15h d'activité de
formation et d'insertion vous votez
contre quand on vote des mesures pour
faciliter l'accès à l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap vous
votez contre quand on vote des mesures
pour faire en sorte que le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
qui permet la formation des demandeurs
d'emploi qui a permis de multiplier par
2 et demi le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi étant formé c'est l'objectif de
la loi plein emploi qui sera soumis au
vote de l'assemblée tout à l'heure vous
avez voté contre chacun des articles
monsieur le député le Front national
dénonce la sistana mais ne fait rien ni
pour l'emploi ni pour sortir celles et
ceux qui celles et ceux qui sont plongés
merci beaucoup monsieur
la parole est à Madame Blandine brocard
pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des solidarités et
des familles madame la ministre 3
millions plus de 3 millions c'est le
nombre d'enfants de femmes d'hommes qui
aujourd'hui en France ne mangent pas à
leur faim souffre de précarité
alimentaire comme il est coutume de dire
par fausse
pudeur les différentes crises qui se
succèdent depuis 4 ans dans notre pays
ont accentué les difficultés des
Français les plus
démunis la générosité de nos concitoyens
l'engagement des associations et de
leurs bénévoles l'action résolue de
l'État et des collectivités apporte des
réponses à la lutte contre ce fléo
l'Union européenne propose également des
programmes de lutte contre la précarité
alimentaire ainsi le fond européen
d'aide au plus démunis a été doté de 3,3
milliards d'euros pour sa programmation
2014-2020 dont 443 millions d'euros ont
été alloués à la France ce fond permet à
l'état d'acheter des denrées
alimentaires pour les plus pauvres et de
les distribuer à quatre associations
caritatives les restos du cœur le
Secours populaire la Croix Rouge et la
Fédération française des Banques
Alimentaires j'ai été alerté il y a
quelques jours par le Secours populaire
justement sur le fait qu'une partie de
ce fond N aurait pas été totalement
engagé alors même que la date limite
pour cela est fixée au 31 décembre de
cette année soit dans quelques semaines
pouvez-vous m'assurer madame la ministre
que la totalité de ce vond sera engagé
dans les délais d'autre part pour la
période 2022-2027 l'Union européenne a
fléché 647 millions d'euros pour le
nouveau programme soutien européen à
l'aide alimentaire au sein du Fond
Social Européen plus avec un financement
de 90 % des dépenses effectuées
pouvez-vous madame la ministre nous
donner des informations sur le pilotage
de ce fond et plus généralement sur les
actions de l'État pour lutter contre la
fin je vous remercie merci beaucoup ma
cher collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier verrand ministre en charge du
renouveau démocratique et est
porte-parole du gouvernement merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Blandine brocard je ne suis pas ministre
des Solidarités ou plus mais madame
berger est en déplacement avec le
président de la République et me prie de
répondre à sa place d'abord merci
d'avoir souligné le le soutien de
l'Europe
parce qu'il faut qu'on insiste à chaque
fois que l'Europe intervient dans le
quotidien des Français et c'est l'Europe
qui intervient en soutien de l'aide
alimentaire dans notre dans notre pays
ça existe depuis
1987 pour la période
2014-2021 le soutien est passé par deux
programmes le Fond Européen d'AD plus
démuni et le plan Ract ce dernier ce
dernier estant mis en place pour faire
face à la crise sanitaire en particulier
au total ces deux programmes ont
représenté 691 millions d'euros de
crédit dont 603 apportés par l'Union
européenne et 88 millions d'euros
apporté par la France ces crédits ils
ont permis aux quatre grandes
associations d'aide alimentairire les
restos du cœur les Banques Alimentaires
le Secours populaire et la Croix-Rouge
qui représente 90 % des distributions de
bénéficier d'environ 90000 tonnes
d'achat de produits annuels et ce au
bénéfice de leur 4 millions de
bénéficiaires concrètement qu'est-ce qui
se passe c'est France agrimaire qui
lance des marchés pour une trentaine de
produits définis avec les associations
concernées et donc même si l'Union
européenne cofinance très largement ces
programmes les crédits sont d'abord avan
par les États avant d'être ensuite
remboursé après une procédure de
contrôle approfondie qui peut prendre
entre 1 et 3 ans pour la période
2014-2021 France agrimaire a dépensé 738
millions d'euros dans le cadre des
marchés d' alimentaires au-delà donc du
plafond de remboursement par l'Union
européenne après les contrôle une partie
des dépenses effectuées n'est pas
reconnue comme éligible et la France a
donc fait le choix d'adopter une
approche proactive ça permet de
compenser le taux de chute que vous
abordez observerz lors de contrôle
rigoureux de l'Union européenne et à la
France de ne pas perdre de crédit
européen et à ce jour l'ensemble des
dépenses l'ensemble des dépenses
réalisées est encore en cours pour son
examen des appels de fonds importants
vont notamment être réalisés très
prochainement pour un montant de plus de
150 millions d'euros quoi qu'il en soit
la France a bien utilisé tous les
leviers à sa disposition pour maximiser
l'utilisation des fonds européens en
faveur de l'aide alimentaire merci
beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
Président vot pour le groupe
socialisteadame présidente madame la
Première ministre la semaine dernière
l'Assemblée nationale votit à
l'unanimité à l'initiative du groupe
socialiste et avec l'AVE favorable du
ministre en charge du budget une aide
exceptionnelle destinée aux familles
monaparentales vivant sous le seuil de
pauvreté entre 115 et 200 Éros pour
aider 600 FAM 600000 familles à terminer
une annniee difficile après une
inflation alimentaire parmi les plus
fortes d'Europe pour l'essentiel des
mamans solo et leurs enfants pour les
tout est difficile se nourrir se loger
se chauffer et nous observons toutes et
tous dans nos circonscriptions voilà la
raison pour laquelle nous avons fait de
ce sujet un groupe de travail
transpartisan avec mon collègue Philippe
Brun une mesure urgente et nécessaire
dont la représentation nationale peut
être fière alors que le Secours
Catholique après le Secours populaire
après les restos du cœur a lancé un cri
d'alarme et pointé du doigt une
féminisation de la pauvreté dont nous
devons nous inquiéter autant que nous
mobiliser mais voilà il y a quelques
jours alors que beaucoup de familles
partageaient un soulagement bien
temporaire et bien relatif le ministre
de l'Économie le ministre de tutelle de
son collègue du budget alors même que
cette loi n'est pas encore votée à titre
définitif juger à propos de cette prime
de Noël je le cite c'est de l'argent
dépensé pour
rien après Bruno demande voici Bruno dém
madame la Première ministre pouvez-vous
nous dire si venir en aide à des mamans
seules qui n le 15 du mois que la
lumière dans leur frigo c'est venir en
aide à des enfants pauvres qui ne
connaîtront pas les joies des cadeaux de
fin d'année c'est de l'argent dépassé
dépensé pour rien pour des familles qui
quoi ne seruraient rien madame la
Première ministre dites-nous que doit-on
comprendre que votre autorité est mise
en cause que préférez-vous avoir tort
avec Bruno Le Maire ou raison avec la
représentation nationale trè bien
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président la
parole est à madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Valot je crois qu'on est sur
un sujet trop sérieux pour se prêter à
des polémiques comme vous êtes en train
de le faire et je peux vous assurer je
peux vous assurer que je suis
parfaitement consciente que la forte
inflation que l'on connaît depuis ces
derniers mois pèse sur le quotidien de
nos concitoyens c'est l'inflation
effectivement liée à la reprise post
covid et à la guerre en Ukraine et je
peux vous assurer aussi monsieur le
Président que depuis le premier jour la
majorité mon gouvernement est mobilisé
pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
Français et nous avons protégé le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens plus
qu'aucun autre pays en Europe c'est le
sens des dispositifs exceptionnels sur
l'énergie les boucliers tarifaires je
rappelle que c'est 46 milliards d'euros
pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
Français c'est le sens de l'indem unité
carburant travailleur que nous allons
reconduire en 2024 et qui bénéficiera
désormais à 60 % de nos concitoyens pour
mieux protéger les classes moyennes
c'est le sens encore des mesures prises
pour lutter contre l'inflation
alimentaire je pense au panier
anti-inflation qui concerne qui concerne
plus de 5000 produits et vous aurez
l'occasion dans quelques instants je
crois de voter le projet de loi qui
permet d'accélérer les négociations
commerciales pour accélérer la baisse de
l'inflation alimentaire nous sommes par
ailleurs attentifs et je vous remercie
de me donner l'occasion de le dire au
pouvoir d'achat des plus modestes la
revalorisation des prestations sociales
l'indexation des pensions l'indexation
du barê de l'impôt sur le revenu c'est
25 milliards d'euros dans le projet de
loi de finance et le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
puis je parlerai aussi de l'augmentation
des plus petites retraites je vous
rappelle qu'avec la réforme des
retraites il va il y a une
revalorisation des pensions minimales
600 € par an pour 1,7 million de nos
concitoyens et je vous confirme monsieur
le député que nous avons accepté un
amendement de votre groupe qui porte une
préoccupation largement partagée sur les
bancs de la majorité pour mieux
accompagner les familles isolées c'est
un combat que mène la majorité avec par
exemple le versement automatique des
pensions pour les familles et pour les
mares célibataires je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
première ministre la parole est à Madame
Julie delpèche pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'État chargée de l'enfance
madame la ministre ce samedi aura lieu
la 8e journée européenne pour la
protection des enfants contre
l'exploitation et les abus sexuels près
de 13 % des femmes et 5 % des hommes
disent avoir été victimes d'abus sexuel
durant leur enfance ces chiffres sont
effroyables ils cachent une réalité
souvent très très difficile à évoquer
pour nombre de nos concitoyens les
médecins le disent un enfant victime
d'abus c'est une vie entière affectée
détruitite souvent abîmé toujours leur
existence ne ressemble à aucune autre
leur douleur nous oblige et nous leur
devons notre dévouement pour que plus
personne ne puisse subir de telles
atrocités s'il nous reste bien
évidemment du chemin à parcourir afin de
notamment libérer la parole je souhaite
tout d'abord saluer ici notre prise de
conscience collective autour de ces
sujets qui se voit renforcé par la
campagne lancée contre l'inceste je
souhaite à ce titre saluer les progrès
introduits par le gouvernement et la
majorité tout particulièrement depuis
2021 ainsi que le travail transpartisan
qui a conduit à l'adoption en deuxème
lecture d'un texte essentiel hier soir
avec la réforme de la gouvernance de la
protection de l'enfance le contrôle
systématique des antécédents judiciaires
des encadrant la désignation des
référents contre les violences dans les
établissements sociaux et
médicau-sociaux la mise en place d'un
référentiel unique partagé ou encore une
meilleure prise en charge des cas de
prostitution sur mineurs nous avons mis
en place des outils importants pour la
protection de nos enfants madame la
ministre je sais et salue votre
engagement sur ces sujets ainsi que
celui du gouvernement je souhaiterais
savoir quelles sont les pistes
envisagées afin de poursuivre cette
lutte notamment contre l'inceste et les
abus sexuels sur les mineurs je vous
remercie je vous remercie ma chè
collègue la parole est à Madame
Charlotte cobel ministre en charge de
l'enfance merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés madame la
députée Julie delpèche merci de rappeler
une nouvelle fois ce chiffre intolérable
ces chiffres intolérables que nous
devons marteler tant qu'ils ne bougeront
pas un enfant est effectivement victime
dans ce pays dans notre pays toutes les
3 minutes de violence sexuelle merci
aussi de rappeler la réalité de temps de
vie d'enfants puis d'adultes brisés par
ces violences contre lequell nous devons
vont lutter c'est pour cela que le le
président de la République en a fait une
priorité de ce quinquena et c'est pour
cela que la première ministre il y a un
an déjà on a fait la priorité de
l'action du comité interministériel de
l'enfance nous avons fait déjà un
certain nombre de choses dans le
précédent quinquena et encore dans ce
quinquena vous en avez rappelé la teneur
je pourrais rappeler la la
généralisation des uapè dans tous les
départements la création et le
formidable travail de la commission
indépendante sur la incest les
infractions sexuelles sur enfants je
vous rappellerai aussi la campagne choc
que nous avons fait pour essayer de
sensibiliser et de bouger tout le monde
beaucoup de choses ont été fait
vous-même avez agi et hier nous pouvons
saluer cette adoption à l'unanimité de
la proposition de loi en 2ème lecture de
Madame Santiago c'est un formidable
outil à la disposition de la protection
des enfants mais il nous faut continuer
à agir et je le crains le plan qui sera
présenté lundi prochain par la première
ministre ne sera pas le dernier plan
parce qu'il nous faut agir contre des
pratiques une culture plus que
millénaire nous irons effectivement à
nous proposerons un certain nombre de
mesures nouvelles en nous appuyant sur
les préconisations faites par la civise
toujours avec quatre axes importants la
prévention le repérage l'accompagnement
des victimes et bien évidemment la
répression des auteurs de ces violences
il nous faut évidemment continuer à nous
battre maintenir le formidable élan
lancé par la civise il nous faut
évidemment nous mobiliser tous je compte
sur vous et vous pouvez compter sur moi
merci bec merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Maxime
Lenet pour la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à la ministre de la
transition énergétique madame panier
runaché au printemps dernier vous avez
cherché à imposer la dissolution de
l'Institut de radio protection et de
sûreté nucléaire dans l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire nous vous avons battu
après un rapport prétexte de l'opexte
vous revenez avec un nouveau projet de
loi pour mettre fin à la séparation de
l'expertise et de la décision en deux
entités distinctes l'incompréhension
reste totale et constitue le premier
motif d'opposition des salariés de
l'IRSN où les démissions ont progressé
de 50 % et même de l'ASN mais son
président a vendu la mèche la semaine
dernière la fusion vise notamment à
répondre aux exigences de nouveaux
opérateurs ces start-up qui pourrai
demain exploiter des petits réacteurs
nucléaires appelés SMR partout près des
grandes industries et pas seulement dans
le périmètre des centrales existantes
vous nous avez donc menti le Conseil
constitutionnel a confirmé à deux
reprises que DF dispose d'un monopole de
production d'électricité nucléaire en
France vous allez pourtant confier
celle-ci à des entreprises privées qui
auront passé des contrats avec de gros
clients pour leur livrer de
l'électricité à prix fixe durant
plusieurs années qui peut croire
qu'elles prendront le risque financier
d'arrêter leur réacteur en cas de risque
sur la sûreté comme le faitedf
aujourd'hui avec la garantie financière
de l'État vous nous préparez les
ingrédients de la catastrophe de
Fukushima pour laquelle le Parlement
japonais estime que la responsabilité de
l'accident réside principalement dans la
négligence de l'opérateur et dans la
complaisance de l'organe de
réglementation à son égard la
conjugaison de vos obsessions atomique
et de la main visisible du marché
pourrait ici aussi se traduire en
irradiation bien réelle et en territoire
alors madame la ministre de la trahison
énergétique il est temps de dire la
vérité pourquoi brader la sreté
nucléaire alors que la filière est déjà
confronté à tant d'impass et à la folie
de votre
relance merci
[Musique]
beaucoup la parole est à
Madame ministre de la transition
énergétique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député lé vous n'aimez pas
le nucléaire vous n'aimez pas EDF vous
n'aimez mais surtout surtout vous
n'aimez pas la réalité des faits la
privatisation du nucléaire et donc votre
nouvelle invention pour jeter le
discrédit sur une filière qui réunit des
dizaines de milliers d'hommes et de
femmes qui sont à notre service et qui
chaque matin garantissent la livraison
d'une électricité bas carbone
compétitive et moins cher que dans le
reste de l'Europe moi je veux leur
rendre hommage à ces experts à 220000
personnes qui tous les matins sont sur
notre territoire pour produire et pour
faire en sorte que nous vivons
mieux monsieur le député attaquer le
nucléaire qui permet aux industriels de
produire aux Français de se déplacer de
se chauffer c'est attaquer l'excellence
de la France à croire que vous n'aimez
pas la France à chaque fois que vous
attaquez le nucléaire c'est aussi le
travail de l'IRSN et de l'ASN que vous
portez vous parlez de privatisation
monsieur le député mais qui a organisé
la montée au capital de DF c'est ce
gouvernement qui vient de prendre la
décision d'éteindre les tarifs
réglementés aux très petites entreprises
c'est ce
gouvernement qui est en train de
renforcer l'autorité administrative
indépendante qui gère notre sûreté
nucléaire c'est ce gouvernement alors
foin de vos mensonges monsieur le député
pendant que vous racontez des bobars
nous agissons concrètement pour lancer
le nucléaire car le succès de cette
relance et ce n'est pas le moi qui le
dit c'est l'office
public c'est l'office publique des choix
scientifiques et technologiques du
Parlement pardonnez du peu dans son
rapport de juillet ça passe par cette
nouvelle autorité qui va permettre non
seulement d'améliorer les procédures
pour répondre au défis de la relance de
garantir l'indépendance de l'autorité
vis-à-vis des exploitants nucléaires et
du gouvernement de renforcer la
transparence vis-à-vis du public et de
rendre attratif méti voilà la réalité
monsieur le
député la seule bonne nouvelle dans tout
ça c'est qu'à force de tout casser c'est
vous qui allez empêcher la relance du
nucléaire dans le
pays la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre-Henri Dumont pour les
républicains merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre depuis
plusieurs jours les habitants de mon
département sont frappés par de
terribles inondations consécutives à des
précipitations inédites au nom des
républicains je tiens à leur témoigner
notre soutien le plus absolu nous
remercions les services de l'État les
forces de l'ordre et de secours les élus
locaux et les citoyens qui uvrent au
quotidien afin de limiter les dégâts et
mettre en sécurité les personnes les
animaux et les biens aujourd'hui alors
que nous vivons sous la menace de
nouvelles précipitations et donc de
nouvelles crues l'heure est à l'entraide
demain nous devrons penser nos plais et
protéger notre territoire de nouvelles
inondations face à ces deux défis l'État
ne peut pas dérobé le fond de solidarité
nationale annoncé par le président de la
République ce matin est un premier pas
mais semble déjà largement insuffisant
pour répondre au besoins immédiats de
tous se frapper par la montée des eau et
ne sera efficace que si les assurances
débloquent rapidement les fonds depuis
plusieurs années nous vous alertons avec
les élus locaux sur la situation
catastrophique du système des
wateringues essentielle à l'évacuation
des eau dans le pôle d'air un système
qui souffre d'un sous-investissement
chronique depuis le désengagement de
l'État consécutif à la mise en place de
la gemapi faisant exclusivement porter
la prévention des risques d'inondation
sur les contribuables locaux nous
privant de la solidarité nationale en
réponse à nos alerte nous av'avons
obtenu de la part du gouvernement
qu'ignorance ou mépris c'est ce mépris
que nous payons aujourd'hui face à
l'ampleur de la catastrophe qui nous
frappe maises concitoyens sont exaspérés
les bouleversements climatiques la
brutalité des précipitations la montée
du niveau des océans mettent gravement à
mal notre système d'évacuation des eaux
à la mer sans investissement massif nous
aurons à subir demain après-demain de
nouvelles in fond nous demandons la
création d'un fond exceptionnel
d'investissement financé par l'État afin
de construire de nouveaux ouvrages de
retenu des nouvelles pompes de rejets à
la mer en particulier dans le calisie
mais aussi pour curer les canaux les
watanges et consolider les berges
allez-vous madame la Première ministre
répondre au cris de désespoir des
habitants et des élus de mon département
je vous remercie je vous remercie mon
cher collègue la parole est à Madame
Dominique fort ministre en charge des
collectivités territoriales et de la
rurale
madame la Présidente merci mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
Pierre-Henri
Dumont très surprise par vos propos
d'ignorance de mépris que vous
percevez je voudrais tout d'abord
souligner le soutien du gouvernement
mais aussi de vous tous j'en suis
certaine pour les sinistrés de la
succession
d'unempérie qui touche le pas de calis
je pense vous AZ écoué attentivement les
éléments de réponse aux députés
précédents qui m'ont interpellé sur ce
ce sujet et je vais compléter les
services de l'État ont mené de
nombreuses interventions d'évacuation en
amont afin de limiter le nombre de
blessés et les conséquences humaines de
cette catastrophe ce n'est pas moins de
[Musique]
61191 personnes qui ont été évacuées à
ce à ce titre je veux souligner la
mobilisation remarquable des sapeurs
pompiers qui ont procédé à ces
opérations je vais vous répondre
monsieur le député si vous avez un brin
de patience 935 Sapur pomp et forque for
militaire de la sécurité civile qui sont
mobilisés donc 410 qui viennent en
provenance de toute la France au service
de nos sinistrés de très importants
moyens humains et de pompage ont été
déployés afin de vider les zones
inondées de protéger les digues ces
actions sont essentielles pour éviter
une dégradation de la situation mais
aussi pour permettre un retour le plus
rapide possible à une vie normale que ce
soit pour les particuliers et pour les
entreprises à ce jour il est en peu tôt
pour dégager un chiffrage global de la
catastrophe il est en effet nécessaire
d'attendre le retrait des EOS comme je
le rappelais juste précédemment le
gouvernement se tient au côté des
sinistrés des élus locaux et du tissu
économique le je vais vous
répondre le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outremères Gérald armanin et le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires étent sur
place mercredi dernier pour tout
simplement bien sûr prouver notre
solidarité prendre la mesure et prendre
les décisions le président de la
République est également sur place en ce
moment le dispositif de catastrophe
naturelle est passé en procédure
accélérée en ce début d'après-midi je
vous remercie merci merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est à Madame ah
excusez-moi vous avez 3 secondes allez-y
madame la ministre vous prouvez que vous
n'y connaissez rien votre réponse est en
dessous de tout je vous remercie la
parole est à Madame mote petit pour le
groupe démocrate
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Éducation nationale depuis
le 29 septembre plusieurs établissements
scolaires sont touchés par d'incessantes
alertes à la bombe et intrusion qui
perturbent leur fonctionnement en
provoquant évacuation ou fermeture dans
le Val de Marne particulièrement impacté
le lycée champelin dans ma
circonscription détient le malheureux
record du nombre d'alertes en Île de
France sur 40 alertes dans la région ce
licé en comptabilise la moitié au-delà
de la question de sécurité qui mobilise
nos forces de l'ordre je vous interpelle
sur la continuité pédagogique mise à mal
depuis 2 mois par des évacuations
parfois quotidienne et une
désorganisation des cours en conséquence
avec plus de la moitié des heures de
programme annulé le désespoir des élèves
est palpable parents et professeurs
s'inquiètent à la perspective des
examens et plusieurs questions se
posent comment permettre le rattrapage
des heures de cours quand
heur ont été perdues à champelin par
exemple comment renseigner parcours sup
en janvier quand on sait que la
plateforme intègre des absences pourtant
ici bien involontaire un bac 100 %
contrôle continu peut-il être envisagé
pour ces établissements une solution
alternative à cours à distance a été
mise en place pctuellement mais elle
fait écho chez certains la période de
confinement mal vécu par beaucoup
d'élèves la plateforme ent n'étant pas
sécurisée les cours virtuels ont subi
des intrusions de personnes non
identifiées et mal intentionnées pulsant
même les professeurs de leur classe
virtuelle enfin elle n'est pas adaptée
aux enseignements pro et BTS monsieur le
ministre je ne doute pas que des
solutions soient recherchées activement
mais l'absence de communication attise
l'incompréhension et le sentiment
d'abandon le temps passe et la colère
des parents et des professeurs se fait
plus forte de jour en jour aussi quelle
réponse concrète pouvez-vous apporter
aujourd'hui à ses élèves à ses
enseignants et à ses professeurs je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Prisc evau ministre en charge
de la jeunesse et du
SNU merci madame la présidente madame la
députée ma petit merci beaucoup pour
cette question et je me permets de
répondre en place et lieu de Gabriel
Atal ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la jeunesse qui est retenu cet
après-midi à Marseille oui vous avez
raison depuis le mois de septembre ce
sont
996 fausses alertes à la bombe que nous
ressensons dans notre pays sur ces
996 alertes à la bombe ce sont
788 dans le seul endroit de nos
établissement scolaires alors face à
cela et je rejoins vos propos nous
devons en premier lieu saluer la
mobilisation de tous bien évidemment en
premier lieu l'équipe éducatif les chefs
d'établissement les enseignants
également nos forces de l'ordre les
gendarmes les policiers et nos services
de secours qui sont sur le pied sur le
qui vivent pour assurer la sécurité de
l' enierrté des personnels au sein des
établissements scolaires comme de nos
enfants bien évidemment face à cela je
tiens également à rappeler quelque chose
peut-être d'utile les fa les fausses
alertes à la bombe mobilisent
inutilement nos forces de sécurité elles
permettent aussi de retarder
malheureusement l'intervention de nos
forces de sécurité et de secours auprès
de celles et ceux qui en ont réellement
besoin
elle en cours elle elle participe à en
courir à celles qui en sont comppables à
30000 € d'amende et 2 ans d' em
prisonnement depuis le mois de septembre
54 personnes ont été interpellées dont
30 sur le dernier mois maintenant bien
évidemment je vois votre impatience et
je vais répondre sur la continuité
pédagogique mais permettez-moi de
rappeler ces sujets qui sont importants
parce que peut-être qu'ils auront un
écho et une résonance auprès de celles
et ceux qui en sont coupables
aujourd'hui et qu'ils comprennent qu'ils
ne seront pas gardés dans l'impunité
ensuite sur la continuité pédagogique
bien évidemment nous devons l'assurer
comme la prudence est de d'assurer la
sécurité de nos établissements scolaire
face à ces fausses alertes de façon très
claire nous devons avoir des dispositifs
à l'endroit des jeunes pour des
dispositifs particuliers avec des
extensions d'horair d'ouverture mais
également des stages de réussite et
également des cours de rattrapage une
dotation spécifique sera déployée par le
ministre à cet effet merci merci
beaucoup madame la ministre la parole
est à Madame Christine Engrand pour le
rassemblement
national madame la Présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues 247 communes
inondées 1391 évacuations 2426
interventions de pompiers dont nous
saluons d'ailleurs l'action au côté de
la protection civile et des volontaires
voilà le bilan provisoire à ce jour des
tempêtes siaran Domingo et des
précipitations consécutives sétant
abattu sur le pas de caléis et sur une
partie du Nord aujourd'hui les pompes
manquent pour palier la hausse du niveau
de la mer il a fallu déménager jeudi
soir deux pompes du lac d'Ardre pour les
mettre sur la commune de de balingon les
bassins de rétention sont
sous-dimensionnés ou mal entretenus des
vannes sont cassées voire démontées
c'est le cas actuellement sur la commune
de tournant le maire a fait ce qu'il a
pu et c'est vraiment superbe les
cantonniers communaux ont disparu faute
de moyens les fossées les rivières les
watergang des de wateringu ne sont plus
curés car par endroit pour ne pas
importuner quelques grenouilles ou
anguilles l'on préfère laisser des
personnes âgées les pieds dans l'eau
alors qu'elles sont assujettis à la taxe
gmapi parfois la taxe watering et
parfois au deux dont l'emploiementque
cru de transparence le caractère
exceptionnel de ces phénomènes
climatiques appelle la mise en œuvre
d'un cadre d'exception efficace pour
reconstruire nos vies rapidement une
fois cette catastrophe terminée cela
implique des procédures de déclaration
de sinistre simplifié une franchise
allégée un gel du montant des
cotisations une suspension des
prélèvements fiscaux et sociaux un
engagement de l'État à compenser
l'ensemble des pertes qui ne pourrai pas
être pris en charge par les assurances
je pense aussi à la dépréciation des
biens immobilier je pense notamment à
toutes ces TPE PME à toutes ces petites
exploitations agricoles ces maréchés
pour qui s'assurer coûte coûte trop cher
et que ce gouvernement refuse de
protéger par la solidarité nationale de
la même manière que les autres en cas
d'alléa exceptionnel en parallèle il
faudra adapter le système actuel aux
enjeux climatiques avec des des
investissements pérennes et efficaces il
faudra comprendre que le caractère
exceptionnel de ces intempéries ne
serait occulté les failles d'une
gouvernance illisible en raison de la
multiplicité de ces acteurs dont les
dysfonctionnements et le manque de
moyens ou des moyens mal coordonnés ont
été révélés au grand jour ils nous font
des solution à court terme et à long
terme qu'est-ce que vous envisagez à
l'heure où je vous parle il tombe entre
7 et 9 mm en 3 He merci la parole est à
Madame Dominique fort ministre en charge
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés merci
madame la députée eng grand de saluer le
travail de nos forces civiles et
militaires je les ai indiqué tout à
l'heure les for misisques merci de
saluer le travail de nos élus locaux on
partage le diagnostic vous l'avez dit
c'est 244 communes qui ont fait l'objet
d'une reconnaissance de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle c'était
aujourd'hui et les arrêtés seront pris
demain je l'ai déjà dit précédemment
c'est aussi 50 millions d'euros que le
Président de la République
a annoncé ce sera un abandement
exceptionnel de la dotation de
solidarité des communes alors certains
peuvent penser que ça ne sera pas
suffisant mais aujourd'hui on est en
train de travailler d'abord à l'urgence
ensuite à porter un diagnostic à mesurer
les les besoins en travaux et donc ces
50 millions d'euros ont été décidés dans
l'urgence maintenant et seront dans la
dotation de solidarité des communes
cette dotation de solidarité permet en
plus troisièmement aux collectivité
touché par un événement climatique ou
géologique de bénéficier d'une
subvention de 150000 € à 6 millions
d'euros elle vise la reconstruction la
remise en état des infrastructures
routières des ouvrages d'art des biens
annexes à la voirie des dig des réseaux
de distribution et d'assainissement
d'eau enfin tout ce qui sera
détruit nous nous tenons donc dans
l'urgence au côté de chacun et chacune
qui est touché par cette catastrophe et
nous déployons tous les moyens
nécessaires pour les accompagner dès
aujourd'hui au quotidien sur le moyen
terme que vous appelez de vos vœux mais
bien sûr que nous tirerons et nous
ferons ce que nous appelons un rétex un
retour d'expérience pour effectivement
tirer tous les enseignements de ce
sinistre pour être toujours au côté de
nos concitoyens je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la ministre avant de
donner la parole au prochain orateur je
rappelle qu'à compté de la semaine
prochaine nous reviendrons au rythme de
de séance hebdomadaire de questions au
Gouvernement la séance du mardi
comprendra 18 questions et çaachaffera
donc vers 16h15 16h20 une seconde séance
de 45 minutes vous permettra
d'interroger le gouvernement à l'issue
des du Conseil des ministres le mercredi
à 14h et c'est une expérimentation qui
durera 10 semaines et que nous pourrons
évaluer tous
ensemble tous ensemble à la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Marc Tellier pour le
groupe GD
voil madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres ces derniers
jours le pas decalé a été la scène de
catastrophe sans pareil les tempêtes
successives ont d'abord frappé durement
suivi des crus exceptionnels qui ont
causé des dégâts considérabl ces
déchaînements ont non seulement ravagé
des zones agricoles des entreprises mais
également détruit nos infrastructures
écoles routes et surtout endommager de
nombreuses habitations
derrière cette catastrophe c'est d'abord
des familles dévastées et probablement
beaucoup de rêves brisés qui nous
appartient de reconstruire permettez-moi
de saluer avec le la plus grande
gratitude ceux qui sont en première
ligne pour aider ses familles les
services de la préfecture le département
nos pompiers nos forces de l'ordre les
bénévoles ainsi que tous les élus locaux
leur solidarité mérite notre
reconnaissance la plus profonde
autour de Montreuil surmer des dizaines
de communes et de quartiers sont
transformés en îau isolé presque coupé
du monde c'est la même désolation à
Saint-Omer à blandec à Saint-Étienne
aont et bien d'autres au total ce sont
plus de 250 communes touchées par les
inondations on imagine déjà le coûp de
reconstruction colossale qui dépassera
de loin les capacités financières de ces
communes déjà éprouvé à cela s'ajoute
une catastrophe agricole l'attention
portée par le gouvernement et le
président Emmanuel Macron à cette crise
ne fait aucun doute mais cette attention
doit surtout être la marque d'une
réponse rapide efficace à la détresse de
nos concitoyens mesdames messieurs les
ministres face à cette urgence et audelà
de la reconnaissance de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle quelle mesure
immédiate et surtout
sont envisagé pour soutenir nos
concitoyens les collectivités les
agriculteurs et les entreprises merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Dominique
fort ministre en charge des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député
Tellier je saluer effectivement et vous
remercier pour vos propos à la
destination des services des concentrés
de l'État des préfets des conseillers
départementaux de tous les élus locaux
je suis totalement solidaire de de vos
propos oui aussi pour cet isolement oui
pour ce désolement que vous avez décrit
monsieur le député dont je suis
totalement solidaire alors bien sûr je
vais vous rappeler ce que nous faisons
comme je viens de le dire à plusieurs de
vos collègues donc c'est bien sûr cet
arrêté demain de catastrophe naturelle
c'est bien sûr 50 millions d'euros mais
si il faut plus on verra on travaillera
dessus mais il faut d'abord un
diagnostic et consommer ces 50 millions
d'euros avant de demander plus ensuite
vous dire simplement qu'on noublie
personne les citoyens vous avez parlé
des agriculteurs des citoyens vous avez
parlé des élus locaux vous avez parlé
des entreprises oui tous sont sinistrés
aujourd'hui oui on en est conscient et
oui vous pouvez compter sur moi sur le
fait que l'on va travailler sur ce
retour d'expérience pour être toujours
meilleur au service de ces quatre
populations que je viens de citer merci
monsieur le député je vous remercie
madame la ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel har pour la
franceoumise
merci madame la Présidente collègue
madame la Première ministre samedi à
Lyon une cinquantaine de membres de
l'extrême droite néonazie ont attaqué
une conférence du collectif Palestine 69
après avoir déambulé plus d'une heure
dans les rues avec des barres de fer je
voudrais ici avoir une pensée pour les
victimes de cette attaque d'une grande
lâcheté une des personne présente dira
au service de police avoir reçu des
coups de barre de fer elle en ressortira
avec 15 jours d'ITT au total se blessés
dans la même soirée quatre étudiants en
école d'ingénieur ont été ciblés depuis
le local identitaire la traboule et une
jeune fille a été poursuivie et tabassée
par le groupuscule les remparts 3 jours
d'ITT dès lors nous avons vu sur des
boucles télégramme publ les
protagonistes de ces raides revendiquer
leurs actes je voudrais dire ici
solennellement notre colère madame la
Première ministre pendant que vous
prépariez la marche avec Madame Le Pen
des militants d'extrême droite
s'organisaient pour cibler des personnes
âgées et des jeunes 30 novembre 2022 6
décembre 2022 9 mai 2023 trois courriers
des quatre députés nupes du rô à propos
des d'agression équivalentes rester tous
sans réponse alors comment 50 militants
encagoulé et armés ont pu déambuler près
d'une heure dans les rues sans être
appréhendé ce sont au moins six
agressions en 3 ans qui ont été rendus
public on ne parle pas des autres
qu'attendez-vous pour engager des
dissolutions des groupuscules les
rempars et lion populaire prenez-vous
l'engagement de fermer définitivement
les locaux identitaires que sont la
traboule et la gaugé et de dissoudre
leur association de gestion agissez
madame la Première ministre nous
n'acceptons pas que nos concitoyens
soient attaqués sur la base de leur
couleur de peau du parler de leurs
parents ou de leurs idées de
leursroyances ou de leurs
convictions merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier verrand porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre en charge du
renouveau
démocratique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Amar nous condamnons
avec la plus grande fermeté les
exactions commises par ce groupuscul
d'ultr drroite à Lyon le ministre de
l'Intérieur a eu l'occasion de le dire
la justice de notre pays est saisie au
moins une arrestation a été faite une
enquête va avoir lieu qui permettra
d'avoir des réponses et s'il y a lieu de
dissourre une association organisée à
Lyon comme ça a été le cas d'ailleurs
avec le bastion social qui a été dissour
en 2019 notre main ne tremblera pas nous
luttons monsieur le député contre la
violence nous luttons contre la violence
de l'ultradroite nous nous luttons aussi
contre la violence de l'ultra gauche
quand elle existe monsieur le député
dans votre question qui aurait presque
pu entraîner un consensus vous vous êtes
permis de pointer du doigt la
manifestation en corrélant les actes
commis par cette action ce groupe d'ultr
droite à la manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme en disant pendant que
vous défilz à côté de Madame Marine Le
Pen monsieur le député je vais vous dire
le fond de ma pensée vous luttez contre
l'extrême droite alors arrêtez de la
faire monter vous faites peur aux
Français vous faites peur aux
Français dimanche à la manifestation à
laquelle vous avez refusé de participer
contre l'antisémitisme des habitants de
Grenoble sont venus me voir en disant
vous comprenez Monsieur Mélenchon nous
fait tellement peur qu'on hésite à voter
Madame Le Pen ayez conscience des mots
de vos députés ayez conscience des actes
de madame bonau des actes de Monsieur le
ayez conscience des atrocités racontées
par Monsieur Guire qui a inventé le
révisionnisme avant l'heure ayez
conscience que votre chef Bienaimé
Monsieur Mélenchon fait beaucoup de mal
à notre pays à la cohésion nationale et
qu'il fait monter constamment l'extrême
droite après vous pourrez nous donner le
S d'abord regardez-vous dans une
glasse je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Vincent THB pour le groupe
horizon merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé
monsieur le ministre en juillet en
juillet 2020 le gouvernement s'est
engagé à revaloriser les carrières et
améliorer l'attractivité des métiers de
la santé en signant les accords de
segure de la santé je tiens ici à
rappeler le caractère indispensable de
ces mesures pour nos soignants qui
doivent bénéficier de tout notre soutien
et de notre reconnaissance totale pour
leur engagement dans les hôpitaux civil
or contrairement aux engagements
nationaux les surcouts salariauxx
résultant de l'application de ces
mesures n'ont été et ne sont que
partiellement compensé et mettent en
grande difficultés financière des
établissements de santé en particulier
les centres hospitaliers dans la région
Grand- est si les CHU et les centres
hospitaliers en santé mentale sont
globalement en situation d'équilibre
budgétaire il en est tout autre pour les
centres hospitaliers qui porte
l'essentiel du déficit régional il
représente 2/3 des établissements de la
région et porte près de 94 % du déficit
avec un déficite moyen de 3 millions
d'euros cette situation s'est donc
largement généralisée dégradé entre 2021
et 2022 puisque le déficit de cet
établissement a été multiplié par 16 par
exemple le centre hospitalier de aguenud
de ma circonscription qui a été durant
la dernière décennie en situation d'équ
financé voire bénéficiaire et
aujourd'hui déficitaire depuis 2021 sa
situation se dégrade passant de 1 1,6
million de déficit en 2021 à 6 millions
d'euros en 2022 et un déficit prévu pour
cette année de 15 millions d'euros donc
certes une partie liée à l'inflation des
énergies mais qui représente que 5
millions d'Ur ceci malgré une activité
équivalente voire supérieure au niveau
des actes de santé par rapport à 2019 le
sousfinancement pèse lourdement sur les
centres hospitalier donc monsieur le
ministre ma question est donc simple que
pryezv que prévoyez-vous pardon pour
paser à ces déficites et à la tenue des
engagement de compensation des mesures
de la santé pour ces établissements
essentiels pour nos territoire merci
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Aurélien Rousseau ministre
de la santé et de la
prévention madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député vous soullignez la situation
financière difficile de très nombreuses
hôpitaux de ce pays et il serait vain et
dérisoire de de tenter de quelqu déni
que ce soit la situation financière de
très nombreux hôpitaux de ce pays est
aujourd'hui extrêmement tendue elle est
malheureuse
à la fois structurellement et
conjoncturellement vous avez évoqué
l'inflation structurellement puisque
c'est votre question nous avons et vous
l'avez vous l'avez très justement dit
des situations extrêmement hétérogènes
entre par exemple les Hôpitaux
Universitaires de Strasbourg qui était
l'an dernier qui était à 100 millions de
d'excédents et des établissements comme
le l'hôpital d'agonon qui voyez leur
déficit se creuser c'est pour répondre
structurellement à cette situation que
nous avons engagé dans le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale la
réforme du financement de l'hôpital
parce que oui entre un CHU une clinique
privée et un hôpital plus local la le
financement ne peut pas être le même
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé d'avoir
trois briques de financement une sur
l'apport en terme de santé publque et de
responsabilité populationnelle dans un
bassin de population l'autre sur la
tarification à l'activité et la
troisième notamment pour les hôpitaux
universitaires quand ils ont une grosse
part de recours c'est ainsi que nous
ferons face structurellement à cette
situation mais monsieur le député même
si vous êtes passé rapidement sur ce
point je voudrais souligner que nous
avons aussi une inquiétude particulière
dans la période sur l'inflation je veux
dire ici que je suis en contact
permanent avec les fédération que ce
soit de l'hospitalisation publique ou de
l'hospitalisation privée le gouvernement
ne laissera pas dans l'impasse les
hôpitaux car nous avons aussi des
signaux positifs notamment en terme de
recrutement de soignants il faut que
nous saisissions ces signaux positifs et
que personne ne s'enfonce dans le rouge
merci monsieur le député merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Monsieur gu bricou pour le groupe l
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Industrie en mars dernier
ma circonscription été touchée par une
double annonce aux conséquences lourde
deux sites majeurs de l'industrie
agroalimentaire ont décidé de fermer
leurs unité de production la sucrerie
teréos des COD d'œufre 120 emplois et
l'usine buitonineselé de coder 120
emplois ces fermetures ont eu en raison
de leur caractère brusque et imprévu un
retentissement important au niveau des
médias et un impact social considérable
dans une région qui connaît un un niveau
de chômage très élevé en milieu rural
chaque usine qui ferme est un
déchirement dans le camp Brésil la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des acteurs
qu'il s'agisse des salariés des élus des
syndicats a été
exemplaire nous avons eu de nombreux
contacts et vous vous êtes déplacés
trois fois je vous en remercie j'ai pu
apprécier votre fermeté à l'égard des
entreprises votre action a amorcé une
dynamique permettant d'aboutir à la
reprise annoncée récemment de la
sucrerie teréos des CODU 350 emplois 350
millions de travaux ainsi qu'au rebond
industriel du craési dans le cadre
d'initiative territoire d'industrie
depuis mars en effet plusieurs réunions
avec les services préf torau que je
remercie au passage ont eu lieu afin
d'identifier les entreprises éligibles
cette politique est très prisée des
industriels et les Incit à investir pour
terminer en accord avec nestley vous
vous étiez engagé à ce que le site
Buitoni de coder soit repris avant le 31
décembre mais il y a toujours loin d'une
annonce à la réalisation effective aussi
monsieur le ministre je vous pose la
question qu'en est-il de l'avenir de ce
site tant en ce qui concerne les
salariés que l'immobilier car une usine
vide est un drame pour un territoire
merci je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Roland lescur ministre en
charge de
l'Industrie merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député gcou bricou pardon comme vous
en mars dernier nous avons été frappés
par deux coups de tonner qui ont affecté
votre territoire vous l'avez dit
l'annonce de teréos de la fermeture de
l'usine déc d'œuvre et celle qui a suivi
quelques jours après de NESTLE de la
fure de l'usine buitonie nous avons agi
en collaboration avec les élus le
président de région les élus nationaux
que vous représentez les élus locaux
aussi les maires dans trois directions
d'abord une pression maximale sur les
entreprises pour qu'elles rendent leur
qu'elles remplissent leurs exigences
sociales les deux PSE ont été signés à
l'unanimité des organis des
organisations syndicales des deux
entreprises ensuite vous l'avez dit
dynamiser le territoire investir dans le
territoire via le dispositif de rebon
industriel qui a permis d'identifier un
certain nombre de projets qui vont créer
à eux seuls près de 200 emplois
industriels dans le territoire du
cambrésie et enfin la recherche d'un
repreneur pour chacun des sites vous
l'avez dit fin août l'entreprise agristo
entreprise belge a annoncé investir 350
millions d'euros pour créer 350 emplois
sur l'usine de teréos et hier
l'entreprise NESTLE a annoncé entré en
négociation exclusive avec l'entre
italienne Ital pizza le champion italien
des pizzas surgelé on a aujourd'hui pour
ceux qui n'aiment pas l'entreprise sur
sban et pour ceux qui détestent l'Europe
deux grandes entreprises européennes qui
choisissent la France qui choisissent
votre territoire c'est une leçon la
France est aujourd'hui attractive la
France attire des capitaux attire des
entrepreneurs qui souhaitent bénéficier
de la qualité des employés Françaises et
Français monsieur le député dans 5
on aura créé plus de 450 emplois
industriels grâce à ces tro actions
c'est autant d'emplois industriel qui av
été détruit les 10 années précédentes
nous agissons cette politique elle porte
des résultats et pour finir sur une note
un peu légère on fera des frites belge
et des pizzas italiennes c'est quand
même mieux que l'inverse merci merci
Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur thier
frappé pour le rassemblement
national
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outres Maes monsieur le ministre suite à
un avis de sagesse donné par le
gouvernement le Sénat a donc voté la
suppression de l'Ame proposant son
remplacement par l'Aide médicale
d'urgence nous nous réjouissons d'un tel
vote
mais aussi du réveil inespéré de nos
collègues les républicains après avoir
été la béquille de votre gouvernement
leslr se trouve une nouvelle identité
dans le programme de Marine Le
Pen depuis 2012 mes chers collègues cela
fait plus de 10
ans cela fait plus de 10 ans que Marine
Le Pen propose la suppression de laame
pour la remplacer par l'Aide médicale
d'urgence cette proposition est enfin
nous savons
l'instrumentalisation autour de ce débat
mes chers collègues la France se doit
d'aider les personnes dont l'état de
santé est en danger immédiat mais la
France ne doit pas devenir une terre
d'accueil pour les mots du cotidien
comment Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
pouvons-nous expliquer à certains de nos
concitoyens que des étrangers ont accès
au soins alors que eux-mêmes ne peuvent
se payer certains services de
santé alors Monsieur le Ministre votre
texte sur l'immigration devrait être
présenté dans notre chambre dans les
prochaines semaines ma question est la
suivante allez-vous oui ou non revenir
sur ce vote de sagesse du Sénat votre
vote de sagesse et celui du Sénat
portant la suppression de laame je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau ministre de
la santé et de la
prévention madame la président mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député nous n'avons décidément pas la
même conception du monde de la nation et
de la
République
l'ame l'aide médicale d'État ça n'est
d'abord pas contrairement à ce que vous
dites le même panier de soins ou des
choses que nos compatriotes ne
pourraient pas se payer auquel ils ne
pourrai pas avoir accès c'est un
dispositif sans doute le plus suivi en
terme de dépenses publiques 1,2
milliards de dépenses publiques qui sont
parfaitement suivi et connu et il y a
dans l'ame le premier rapport rendu et
le rapport intermédiaire rendu par
claudevin et Patrick stéphanini aucune
espèce d'effet d'attractivité en matière
d'immigration mais là où nous n'avons
pas la même conception du monde monsieur
le député c'est que quand on est malade
il ne suffit pas d'être dans une
situation d'urgence pour que la
République puisse prendre en charge et
vous soigner et uniquement uniquement
sur le seul terrain de l'intérêt
financier nous n'aurions jamais intérêt
à ce que ces personnes se rendent toutes
à l'hôpital nous avons l'intérêt à ce
que en terme de prévention notamment des
maladies infectieuses de la pneumologie
à ce que la médecine de ville prenne
toute sa part dans dans la prise en
charge des malades donc non monsieur le
député je suis au regret de vous dire
que le gouvernement a très clairement
dit qu'il n'était pas favorable à l'aide
médicale d'urgence que nous que tout
sujet peut-être évidemment discuté laame
fait l'objet d'une mission nous en
discuterons mais ne confondons pas un
texte sur l'immigration et une question
de santé publique merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre monsieur le député
allez-y monsieur le député oui monsieur
le ministre vous l'avez rappelé avec
l'inflation le budget des hôpitaux
publics s'annonce être en difficulté
pour l'année 2024 la suppression de la
me représenterait économie de 1,2
milliard d'euros au maximum merci
beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député vous alliez
manifestement une vision de la nation
que je ne partage pas et puis
malheureusement une méconnaissance
complète du système si nous supprimions
l'ame ce sont autant de dépenses qui
iraient directement dans le budget des
hôpitaux dont tu as parler votre
collègue du Barin tout à l'heure ça
serait très préoccupant pour les
hôpitaux l'ame est le plus le dispositif
le plus protecteur pour les hôpitaux
dans notre pays merci beaucoup monsieur
le
ministre la parole est à Madame Sandrine
Rousseau pour le groupe écologiste ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Justice ah il a pas l'air
d'être là alors aujourd'hui dans
l'atmosphère feutrer des instances
européennes se discutent les termes
d'une directive sur la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes le 8 mars
2022 la Commission européenne annoncé le
projet de lutter contre ces violences
viol mutilation cyber harcèlement
partage consenti d'image intime ou
encore mariage forcé comme vous l' écrit
maè ma collègue Francesca Pasquini
pardon la France fait obstacle à
l'intégration du viol dans ce texte
pourtant en France une femme toutes les
7 minutes est concernée en France
99,4 % des viols ne seront jamais
sanctionnés ici ce noue quelque chose du
patriarcat l'impunité des crimes commis
par les hommes sur le corps des femmes
et des enfants comprenez-vous la colère
des femmes monsieur le ministre
la loi française telle qu'elle est
écrite aujourd'hui suppose que les
femmes sont toutes et tout le temps a
priori consentantes il faut qu'il y ait
menace surprise ou contrainte pour que
la justice puisse éventuellement statuer
la France doit entrer dans le 21e siècle
oui la définition du viol est un acte
sexuel sans sans consentement
pouvez-vous affirmer devant cette
assemblée que la position de la France
est de s'opposer comme la Hongrie de
Victor Orban à ce que la définition
commune européenne du viol soit un
rapport non
consenti je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame berangerre Couillard ministre
en charge de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes et de la lutte contre les
discrimination merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Rousseau je
voudrais déjà rappeler que la la
législation française est l'une des plus
répressives d'Europe elle réprime les
crimes de viol de 15 ans de prison et
jusqu'à réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité s'agissant des faits aggravés
je voudrais également rappeler que
l'absence de consentement de la victime
d'infraction sexuelle est au cœur de
notre définition juridique les critères
violence contrainte menace ou surprise
dans le droit français servent justement
à caractériser l'absence de consentement
de la victime à la relation sexuelle je
vous rappelle madame la députée que
l'Europe n'a pas de définition à ce jour
et que la Commission européenne ne
propose que deux critères la menace et
la violence elle ne propose pas la
contrainte et la surprise ce que vous ne
propose ce que vous ne précisez pas
Madame la député c'est c'est que si on
intègre l'article 5 à la directive il y
a aussi un risque majeur de voir la
directive entièrement annuler et donc
toutes ces avancées madame la députée
vous ne précisez pas non plus que vous
défendez une position qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité des association féministe
beaucoup d'entre elles craignent la
modification de la définition vous savez
une femme peut avoir dit oui et ne pas
être consentante et une femme peut ne
pas avoir dit non et ne pas être
consentante nous devons continuez par
contre vous avez raison à lutter contre
les violences sexuelles et depuis 4 ans
il y a une meilleure prise en charge
notamment le nombre d'affaires de viol
ou d'agression sexuelle qui ont été
signalé au parquet qui ont quasiment
doublé en passant de 20000 à 40000 entre
2017 et 2021 le nombre de condamnations
aussi pour viol a augmenté de près de 40
% sur la même période et 98 % des peines
sont de 11 ans de prison en moyenne
alors soyez assuré madame la députée de
notre détermination et preuve en vous
avez pas dit non plus que la France est
à l'initiative de cette
directive je vous remercie madame la
ministre madame
Rousseau pour les seuls 0,6 % de
condamnation des viols en France nous
qui sommes sans passer les femmes vous
qui n'avons pas
d'O je vous remercie vous n'avez plus la
parole la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Dunoyer pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre madame la Première
ministre depuis près d'un an maintenant
état indépendantiste et non
indépendantiste se mobilise pour écrire
collectivement l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie dans le cadre d'un
grand accord et en vocation à être
constitutionnalisé TR maîre mot guide
pas le respect des accords d'abord comme
l'aé président de la République le 26
juillet dernier il n'est pas question de
revenir sur les acquis des accords de
Nea et de Matignon qui ont permis de
bâtir la paix ils sont disait-il notre
héritage un exemple pour le monde un
exemple français un exemple
calédonien C ces accords aujourd'hui il
nous faut les poursuivre ils sont nés
dans le sang d'une guerre civile qui n'a
pas dit son nom ils sont nés aussi du
courage de leaders qui ont subravé leur
propre camp
et ils sont nés enfin d'un État qui a su
se montrer innovant et impartial ils ont
inventé un chemin qu'il nous faut
poursuivre dans le respect du résultat
des trois référendums le deuxième maître
mot c'est le dialogue aujourd'hui une
part de la sensibilité indépendantiste
n'est pas présente autour de la table
malgré les efforts engagés par le
gouvernement récemment encore dans le
cadre des réunions initiées au
commissariat de la République c'est
pourquoi Calédonie ensemble a pris
l'initiative d'engager il y a quelques
semaines un dialogue entre formation
politique calédon
tous les groupes indépendantistes du
Congrès ont accepté d'y participer cette
dynamique calédonienne pourrait inciter
certains à reprendre les discussion avec
l'État notamment dans la perspective de
laavenue prochaine du ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outres mèes le
dernier mtromement enfin c'est le
consensus l'aire des actes unilatéraux
est derrière nous madame la Première
ministre les statuts imposés dans les
années 80 nous ont conduit au chaos le
consensus est le seul chemin qui vaille
même s'il est escarpé madame la Première
ministre ma question est donc la
suivante face aux difficultés et au
temps désormais contraints comment le
Gouvernement entend-il poursuivre ses
efforts de dialogue pour favoriser
l'émergence d'un projet d'avenir
partager merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Philippe du Noyer
depuis plusieurs mois le président de la
République et le gouvernement s'emploie
à créer les conditions d'un travail
serein et constructif avec les acteur
politique de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie alors que le
processus politique prévu par l'accord
de numea est arrivé à son terme et que
les Calédoniens ont choisi de demeurer
français ce travail est la condition
indispensable pour bâtir l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie comme vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le Député cela passe par le
dialogue avec tous indépendantiste et
non indépendantistes dans toutes leurs
composantes c'est dans cet esprit que
j'ai reçu l'ensemble des délégations
politiques calédonienne à Matignon début
septembre je veux saluer l'esprit de
responsabilité qui a présidé aux
derniers échanges sur le projet d'accord
proposé par le gouvernement les travaux
doivent se poursuivre pour parvenir à un
accord politique d'ici la fin de l'année
conformément à l'objectif fixé par le
président de la République c'est pour
cela que le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outremaires Géral d'armanin se
rendra à nouveau en Nouvelle-Calédonie
fin novembre nous souhaitons et œuvrons
à la participation active de tous les
acteurs politiques représentatifs pour
définir l'avenir institutionnel du
territoire un accord doit permettre de
régler des questions aussi importantes
que la citoyenneté calédonienne le dégel
du du corps électoral
l'autodétermination le statut et les
institutions mais plus largement un
accord permettra d'offrir des
perspectives à l'ensemble des
Calédoniens et je pense en particulier à
la jeunesse calédonienne s'il doit fix
des bases nouvelles le futur accord
s'inscrira dans la continuité des
précédents les accords de Matignon et de
Nea sont des acquis historiques l'état y
est attaché comme les acteurs politiques
calédoniens ces accords ont été rendus
possibles par la volonté commune de
bâtir un avenir dans la paix civile et
par le rôle impartial joué par l'État
les mêmes conditions peuvent et doivent
être réunis aujourd'hui c'est le sens de
l'action de mon gouvernement dans ce
dans ce contexte monsieur le député
Philippe duun noyer je veux saluer votre
entière mobilisation dans la
construction de l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et vous pouvez
compter sur l'engagement sans faille de
mon gouvernement pour bâtir ce projet je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Pierre Vatin pour les
républicains merci madame la Présidente
maises chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
j'ai associé notre collègue les
républicains Yannick nuder
madame la Première ministre je vais vous
parler des tickets restaurant une fois
encore je ne suis pas certain que les
Français qui travaillent puissent vous
comprendre alors que vous allez mettre
fin à une mesure de justice sociale
parce qu'elle est provisoire alors qu'il
y a tant de mesures provisoires que l'on
rend
permanente pourtant ici il s'agit d'une
mesure qui ne coûte rien au budget ultra
déficitaire de la nation il s'agit d'une
mesure qui facilite la vie de nos
compatriotes qui travaillent et qui
bénéficie deavantage des tickets
restaurant payés par le employeur et par
eux-mêmes vous leur aviez permis du fait
du covid et du télétravail d'élargir à
l'ensemble de l'alimentation les achats
des les achats au moyen des dittickets
cela avait aussi un avantage sur leur
pouvoir d'achat ça coûte toujours moins
cher de préparer un repas à la maison
que de l'acheter tout près
malheureusement c'est fini quel est le
fondement humain de cette décision que
mes collègues les républicains et
moi-même ne comprenons pas pourquoi ne
pérenisez-vous pas une idée quand elle
est bonne et qu'elle facilite la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens
salariés je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Jean-Noël barreau ministre en
charge du
numérique madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Pierre Vatin par respect pour
cette hémicycle et ce qu'il représente
je ne vais pas me mettre à chanter vous
m'interrogez sur le le titre restaurant
qui a été créé en 1967 qui bénéficie
aujourd'hui à 5 millions de salariés que
les employeurs les salariés sont
pleinement appropriés que l'État
soutient puisque les exonérations de
cotisation sur les contributions des
employeurs sont à hauteur d'à peu près
1,5 milliard d'euros par an c'est la
raison pour laquelle lorsque Madame
Frédéric puissa sénatrice de liser a
l'année dernière lors de l'examen du
projet de loi pouvoir d'achat déposé un
amendement permettant d'étendre ce
dispositif aux produits qui ne sont pas
directement consommés le gouvernement
l'a soutenu et c'est aussi la Rais
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
Bruno Le Maire Olivia Grégoire ont
engagé une réforme de ce titre
restaurant pour le mod moderniser et le
dématérialiser pour le rendre plus
simple pour les restaurateurs et pour le
sécuriser entre les mains des salariés
et du point de vue des émetteurs alors
le cœur de votre question c'est la
prorogation de la capacité d'utiliser
les titres restaurants pour des biens
qui ne sont pas immédiatement consommés
je veux d'abord préciser que c'est
l'amendement de la sénatrice puissa qui
a borné ce dispositif au 31 décembre
2023 je veux ensuite je veux ensuite euh
m'interroger sur le fait que parmi les
10000 amendements qui ont été déposés
sur les textes financiers cet automne
euh aucun ne visait la prorogation de ce
dispositif mais je veux aussi euh vous
rassurer monsieur le député en vous
disant que Bruno Le Maire Olivia
Grégoire s autorité de la première
ministre ont engagé des discussions avec
les restaurateurs les représentants des
salariés et des employeurs pour que
cette question à laquelle le
gouvernement est très attaché trouve la
réponse la plus appropriée merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre monsieur
Vatin monsieur le ministre je trouve que
votre réponse est bien alambiquée pour
une chose extrêmement simple pour nos
concitoyens c'est encore un coup d'achat
porté au pouvoir d'achat des Français
aussi le nombre de tickets perdus va
augmenter à cause de votre déficit de
connexion avec la vie des Français il
aurait été extrêmement simple de
reprendre au compte du gouvernement
l'amendement de la sénatrice Cusa mais
bien sû je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Claudia
rouau pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre la Bretagne
première région agricole de France se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans une impasse
collectivité régionale syndicat agricole
Chambre d'Agriculture manifestation
d'agriculteur comme ce jour esplanade
des Invalides à Paris courrier
transpartisan de 35 parlementaires
breton tous unanimement vous ont fait
part de leur inquiétude concernant
l'insuffisance de financement des
mesures agro-environnementales et
climatique lors de la première
génération des MAEC de nombreux
agriculteurs bretons conscients des
enjeux se sont engagés vers une
transition
agroécologique soutenu en cela par la
collectivité régionale autorité de
gestion qui n'a jamais refusé aucun
dossier pour cette seconde génération
désormais gérée par l'État et malgré un
cahier des charges de plus en plus
exigeant
2900 exploitations agricoles bretonnes
sont dans l'incertitude car elles
risquent de voir leur demande de MAEC
rejeté ou diminuer pourtant 1 milliard
de plus sur le budget agriculture dans
le cadre du PLF 2024 mais comment
expliquer une baisse de 65 millions
d'euros en autorisation d'engagement et
12 millions d'euros en crédit de
paiement pour lesemec ces chiffres sont
en total contradiction avec la parole du
président de la République qui a promis
un quinquena écologique et cela doit
vitablement passer par une
transformation du modèle
agricole à la suite de la présentation
de la planification écologique il n'est
pas envisageable de revenir sur des
contrats en cours et dé laisser sur le
bord de la route des exploitations
agricoles volontaristes dans la
transition agroécologique en raison
d'une sous-budgétisation des
financements madame la Première ministre
si l'on ne finance pas suffisamment les
MAEC comment les agriculteurs
peuvent-ils encore croire en la parole
publique quel engagement allez donc vous
prendre pour augmenter ce budget à la
hauteur des attentes des agriculteurs et
répondre ainsi aux enjeux
environnementaux je vous remercie merci
beaucoup ma cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Franck rester ministre en
charge des relations avec le Parlement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
rouau le plan stratégique national porte
une ambition forte au service de la
transition agroécologique de
l'agriculture française comme vous le
savez plusieurs dispositifs dont les ma
concour à l'atteinte de cette objectif
et à la valorisation des pratiques
vertueuses du point de vue de la
préservation de la biodiversité et des
ressources naturelles ces dernières
semaines des agriculteurs qui se sont
engagés dans ces démarches vertueuses
ont exprimé des inquiétudes notamment en
Bretagne vous l'avez rappelé sur leur
mise en œuvre dans la nouvelle
programmation de la PAC je tiens tout
d'abord à rappeler que le calendrier de
versement de l'avance des aides de la
campagne 2023 de la PAC a été tenu et
s'est bien déroulé ainsi dès le 16
octobre soit le premier jour permis par
la réglementation européenne le paiement
de l'avance des aides a été versé sur
les comptes des
agricultures soit près de 3,64 milliards
d'euros les MAEC de la campagne 2023
quant à elle ont vocation à être comme
c'est toujours le cas payé à compté du
premier trimestre
2024 nous connaîtrons le besoin précis
seulement après l'instruction des
dossiers MAEC qui démarre après celle
des paiements directs je tiens également
rappeler que la programmation
2015-2020 a été réalisée contjointement
par l'État et les régions les les
briques des mesures étant définies par
l'État l'exercice de la programmation
2023 et les priorisations on été faites
en craek coprésidé par l'État et les
régions comme ce fut le cas en 2015 nous
sommes donc sur une volonté collective
état et région d'un exercice responsable
de priorisation des besoins au regard du
diagnostic
agroenvironnemental du territoire je
rappelle également les 12,5 millions
d'euros de MAEC non surfassiqu à la main
de la région Bretagne qui se sont
également déroulé comme un moyen
d'accompagner les démarches vertueuses
des agriculteurs et qui sont donc à
prendre en compte vous pouvez donc
compter sur la mobilisation la plus
totale du gouvernement et Marc PHENO
afin qu'une solution soit trouvée avec
l'ensemble des coffinanceurs dans
l'intérêt des
agriculteurs merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre allez-y oui merci monsieur le
ministre il en va quand même du devenir
de l'agriculture en Bretagne des enjeux
bien sûr écologiques mais aussi
économiques je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Emmanuel Fernandez pour la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente une
question au ministre de la transition
écologique le Conseil constitutionnel a
récemment reconnu pour la première fois
la protection des générations futures en
affirmant leur droit à vivre dans un
environnement sain dans le dossier
stokamine quelques jours plus tard le
tribunal administrative de Strasbourg a
débouté l'État en suspendant les travaux
d'enfuissement définitif de 42000 ton de
déchets hautement toxi à 500 m de la
naéatique Renan qui alimente en eau 7
millions de personnes face à la
nécessité de remonter à la surface ces
déchets dangereux contenant amiante
cianure arsenic et autres poisons vous
mentez et vous entravez vous mentez en
prétendant que le fait de couler 130000
m C de béton à 500 m sous la nappe
constituerait autour des déchets un
sarcophage prétendument étanche qui
serait un jour peut-être réversible
votre collègue Olivier bestch ment quand
il affirme que la seule alternative
aujourd'hui serait un déstockage à main
nue vous mentez en disant qu'un
déstockage mettrait les mineurs dans un
danger inconsidéré alors même que des
projets bien plus complexes ont été
réalisés en Allemagne et en Suisse vous
entravez les experts indépendants comme
les entreprises volontaires pour le
déstockage en refusant l'accès à la mine
vous entravez le déstockage en
entretenant pas suffisamment les
galeries et le puits comme vous en
enjoint pourtant la justice quand des
associations s'opposent à vos méfait
vous tentez de les dissoudre fort
heureusement votre gouvernement
autoritaire et écosidaire vient de subir
une lourde défaite avec l'annulation par
le Conseil d'État de la dissolution des
soulèvements de la terre Gérald haranin
va pouvoir ravaler son terme délirant
d'écoterrorisme né dans son imaginaire
horwellen monsieur Béchu l'enfouissement
définitif des déchets toxiques à
Stocamine serait un véritable échocy
prémédité combien de défaites singlantes
devrez-vous encore subir avant de
prendre acte que la seule solution
raisonnable est de déstocker
stockamine je vous remercie la parole
est à Madame Dominique fort ministre en
charge des collectivités territoriales
et de la ruralité merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
Fernandez stockamine c'est une
installation de stockage et vous le
savez très bien sousterrain de déchets
dangereux situés dans le haut rein
exploité de 99 à 2002
après de multiples analyses le
gouvernement a décidé en 2014 sur la
présidence de François Hollande de faire
extraire les déchets les plus
susceptibles d'avoir un impact sur la
nappe fréatique d'Alsace et de confiner
les autres déchets à son arrivée au
ministère de la transition écologique
Christophe Béchu a réexaminé le dossier
en veillant à la plus grande
transparence sur les informations dont
il disposait et en organisant de
nombreuses réunions avec les élus et par
parlementaire du territoire le ministre
a décidé en septembre de confiner la
mine sans opération de déstockage
s'appuyant sur 134 études porté par 46
bureaux avec 123 experts confiner dès à
présent stockamine est une décision qui
s'impose à tous pour trois raisons le
délai de confinement minimal est de 42
mois or sous l'effet de la pression les
galeries se referment actuellement sur
même et la mine deviendra inaccessible
dès 2027 2è raison il n'y a pas de
possibilité de mener deux fronts des
travaux de confinement et des opérations
de déstockage trisème raison déstocker
des déchets avant le confinement ferait
peser un risque inacceptable pour les
personnels humains devant intervenir
dans la mine le gouvernement vous ne
partagez pas ce point de vue respectez
le nôtre le gouvernement a donc
travaillé avec les élus locaux sur sur
un plan de confinement qui prévoit
également des conditions de
réversibilité du stockage en anticipant
un possible déploiement de futur
techniques robotique de déstockage la
loi de finan pour 2024 garantit donc le
maintien en sécurité du stockage de ces
déch merci beaucoup madame la ministre
merci monsieur le député 2 secondes
simplement madame la ministre vous ne
maîtrisez visiblement vraiment pas le
sujet je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame Cécile RAC pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie et
des finances monsieur le ministre de par
ces applications le spatial est
aujourd'hui fondamentalement stratégique
pour notre nation de fait le spatial est
devenu un outil majeur de notre
souveraineté souveraineté technologique
industrielle stratégique et militaire
sans le spatial la France et l'Europe
perdrai dans de nombreux domaines leur
autonomie vis-à-vis des grandes
puissances
c'est ce constat qui a conduit les 22
états- membres de l'Agence spatiale
européenne à conclure un accord sur
l'avenir de l'Europe spatiale les 6 et 7
novembre dernier à Séville cet accord
historique marque le retour au premier
plan de la puissance spatiale européenne
l'occasion de souligner le formidable
travail de nos ministères et de notre
agence spatiale dans ces négociations en
affirmant un soutien financier important
au programme Arian 6 les États européens
ont fait le choix fort de préserver
notre accès autonome à l'Espace pour la
prochaine décennie cet accord marque
également la volonté européenne de
renouer avec l'exploration en se dotant
d'un premier vaisseau cargo qui lui
permettra d'ouvrir la voie au vol habité
enfin cet accord réitère l'engagement
européen pour l'observation de la Terre
outil indispensable pour mener à bien
nos engagements climatiques ces
nouvelles perspectives amèneront la
France à repenser sa stratégie en la
matière l'ouverture à la concurrence des
programmes Industri européen nous impose
de soutenir davantage nos acteurs
français en amont à ce titre une
accélération du déploiement de France
2030 s primordiale notamment en
mobilisant la commande publique aussi
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous nous
préciser comment la France entend tirer
profit de ces nouvelles dispositions et
si le Gouvernement entend produire un
document de politique spatiale nationale
pour accompagner ces changements et
notre industrie je vous remercie bien
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Noël bar ministre en charge du
numérique
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Cécile rilac chacun connaît ici votre
engagement et votre expertise sur ces
sujets aussi je ne peux que vous
rejoindre quand vous saluez l'accord qui
a été trouvé la semaine dernière lorsque
la France sous l'impulsion de Bruno Le
Maire l'Italie et l'Allemagne se sont
accordés ont trouvé un accord qui
constitue un succès majeur et un
tournant décisif pour l'Europe spatiale
avec la sécurisation du modèle
économique d'Arian 6 seul gros lanceur
européen grâce à 340 millions d'euros de
subvention annuell pour les années qui
viennent et grâce à 15 nouveaux
lancements qui viennent s'ajouter au 27
déjà contractualisés et qui donnent un
horizon à notre lanceur Arian 6 grâce
ensuite au soutien réaffirmé à la
nouvelle génération des lanceur
notamment grâce à la mobilisation du
plan France 2030 voulu il y a 2 ans par
le Président de la République qui
consacre 1 milliard et demi d'euros euh
à ces acteurs dont les 2/ers doivent
venir soutenir des acteurs émergents
avec la confirmation du rôle central de
kurou du Centre Spatial guyané comme euh
lieu de lancement de classe mondial pour
l'ensemble de ces acteurs à commencé par
Arian 6 et puis vous l'avez dit avec
l'ambition réaffirmé de faire euh de
l'Europe une puissance de l'exploration
avec un programme euh d'acquisition de
service cargo vous voyez madame la
députée sous l'impulsion sous l'autorité
de de la première ministre le
gouvernement a veillé à ce que l'Europe
des lanceurs soit relancé et cet effort
vient en complément du soutien de la
France à la constellation iris 2
constellation européenne d'Internet très
haut débit qui va servir à garantir
notre résilience en matière de
télécommunication car vous avez raison
une nouvelle fois c'est bien dans
l'espace que se joue une part importante
de notre souveraineté technologique
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
séance des questions gouvernement est
terminé la séance est
suspendue